welcome to this licensing subcommittee
today
um we're welcoming everyone to today's
reconvened meeting of the licensing
subcommittee adjourned on 9th of
december 2021
just a bit of housekeeping
if the fire alarm is activated please
take the stairs down to the reception
area and out of the building to the
green in hawley square which is the
assembly point please do not use the
lifts officers will assist you in
advisement is deemed safe to return to
the council offices
filming of the meeting
i would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured i
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
no
um
nobody's gonna film it okay
um
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls whilst this
meeting is in progress
apologies for absence are there any
apologies for absence no apologies okay
thank you
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest
um
okay agendum item three application for
a full review of the license for faith
in strangers 17 ethelberg president
margate
i call upon mrs phillips the council's
principal litigation sister to explain
to the parties the procedure that we
will be taking during the hearing
thank you good afternoon everyone i'd
like to confirm that the decisions of
the subcommittee are made in accordance
with the licensing act 2003 and are
based on the information that's
presented in this agenda together with
any verbal submissions that's made today
the decisions of the subcommittee
they're not politically based
and the subcommittee will act
impartially and offer a fair and biased
hearing of today's application
as the chair said the hearing today
is of the license and subcommittee which
was adjourned on the 9th of december
2021 for the application for a full
review of the license held by faith in
strangers who are situated at 17
ethelbert crescent margate which was
made by the licensing department to
thank district council as a relevant
licensing authority in accordance with
the act
we will hear the parties in the
following order
first we will hear alison brooke who is
the license and technical support team
manager and she will present a report
secondly we will hear from the
environmental health department who are
represented today by mr ranatunga and
he'll be given
up to 25 minutes to address the
subcommittee on behalf of the
environmental health department then we
will hear from the interested parties
who include members of the public who
have submitted representations
we will hear from mr ruiz gay of
woodward
for the residents who have submitted
their representations
and he will have up to 25 minutes also
to make representations
um there will also be representations
from residents who have submitted
representations and then lastly
from sarah clover who is representing
faith in strangers now after each person
has made their representation um each of
the parties will have an opportunity
to
ask the individual questions
and um members of the subcommittee also
will have an opportunity to ask
questions
in summing up after all the
representations have been made and
questions answered and each
representative will be allowed five
minutes to give a summary and make
any final representations
once all the relevant representations
have been made the subcommittee the
democratic services officer and myself
as the legal officer will leave the
chamber and go into another room to
deliberate and come to a decision on the
application and this should take around
30 minutes after which we will return
back to the chamber whereupon i will
announce the determination of the
subcommittee
madam chair
clover may i be permitted to address you
madam chair on a legal point it has been
notified in advance to your legal
advisor and i've mentioned it this
morning to mister this afternoon forgive
me to mr risque and mr ranatunga
i have indicated that this hearing is
not vires it is ultraviolet is not
lawful
under section 52 of the licensing act
2003.
uh i've also made some written
submissions in relation to the the locus
the ability to
address you
of the environmental health team
represented by mr ranatunga and miss
berry this is because the review
application has been withdrawn
formally withdrawn
the
representations from third parties
that have come in within the statutory
time period are parasitic upon the
review application
and section 52 of the act is very clear
that where there is an application for a
review
a hearing must be convened
and in several places in the section it
refers to the
hearing considering the application and
the relevant representations they are
cumulative they stand or fall together
and this point was raised at the very
inception of the licensing act back in
2007 or 2008 and i have the quotation
here with lay cause which was the legal
advisory
um
agency to dcms the department of culture
media and sport at the time who had the
remit for licensing
they were asked this question they
answered in this way so it was actually
august 2007.
lakehouse recently received a query
regarding whether it's legally possible
to withdraw a review application and if
so how should local authorities deal
with any representations that have been
received in respect of the review
following discussions with the dcms
lake course is now able to offer the
following commentary on this issue that
although there is no express provision
in the act for withdrawal of
applications it should nevertheless be
possible for applicants to withdraw any
application should they no longer wish
to proceed
and since the provisions of the act are
drafted in the same terms for grants
variations and reviews this withdrawal
mechanism must be applied consistently
so it would be applicable to reviews
once the application is withdrawn
legally nothing remains to sustain the
representations
and therefore no hearing would be
required i've set this out in writing
the relevance that it has
is that
in the event that this hearing goes
ahead anyway
and i anticipate you'll be hearing
opposite representations from uh from
the other legal
personages in the room but if the
hearing goes ahead anyway there is
technically no right of appeal to the
magistrate's court because an
ultraviolet's hearing does not trigger
any right of appeal within the
magistrates and it would therefore have
to be taken uh in accordance with the
legal analysis to the high court on a
judicial review
i have to say this now therefore to put
the decision makers for putative
decision makers on notice before they
start to do what it is they think
they're going to do because it may
result in jr proceedings thank you
thank you miss clover i'll need to
consult with um our principal escalation
systems
adam i don't know it's mr anita here on
behalf of environmental health i can
address you on that legal point um if
you so wish but i know you've taken
legal advice
no if you'd like to um um go ahead i'm
grateful um
in short um my position is that the the
point that's made is is wrong um and
it's for these reasons what we know has
happened
um in this case is that there has been
an application made by environmental
health
that has been consulted upon in the
normal way there's no objection to that
process carrying through in the normal
way and representations have been made
it is right to say that in writing on
the 2nd of december of last year
environmental health indicated that they
had taken the decision to withdraw the
application for review
but
following that consultation taking place
and following the receipt of the
application this committee is seized of
the application and this is public
interest
applications under the licensing act
2003 and you are entitled in fact you
must continue to hold the hearing to
hear what um residents and other people
who've made relevant representations
have said
um so that is um the the position the
particular point to get into the legal
niceties of it raised by miss clover is
under section 52
and um as i understand what's said um
section 52 is about the determination of
applications for review subsection 2
states that before determining the
application the authority must hold a
hearing to consider it and any relevant
representations
and i suppose the subtlety of the point
that ms clover raised raises is to say
well firstly you must hold a hearing and
that's my point
but she says to consider it i.e the
application and any relevant
representations necessarily means that
if the application is withdrawn there's
nothing to consider well that can't be
right in my respectful submission
you must hold a hearing to consider both
it i would interpolate and any relevant
representations in the absence of the
application itself i.e we've decided to
withdraw it you still in fact have
received an application you've still
received relevant representations
about the issues that we're dealing with
today which is noise from the premises
and you must hold a hearing to consider
them now
that is
my position on the interpreting the
statute if i needed assistance on that
the
um
the leading practitioners text in
licensing is paterson's and it has
footnotes on various matters one of
which is
engages with this issue
and um
i think all the advocates will be aware
of the commentary to section 52 and what
it says but footnote 1
since it's been raised does refer to the
situation
where um
for whatever reason
the applicant for review no longer
wishes to pursue it and says that it's
withdrawn
in those circumstances the editors of
paterson's and of course this is a
practitioner's text nothing more but
they say the obligation on the part of
the licensing authority is to hold a
hearing for all the reasons really i
would suggest i've outlined now what ms
clover does raise is the lake hall's
guidance and i have seen an email sent
by ms clover to that effect and she does
refer to what
an officer at lakers had commented in
2007 so just to put that in context that
is not statute that is not an authority
from the courts that is not statutory
guidance it's what one officer at lake
course has commented maybe the position
following that issue being raised in
2007 it does not have
any particular status before you it is
an observation
even if that officer got the law right
and i contend that he didn't what he
says is is that once the application is
withdrawn legally nothing remains to
sustain the representations therefore no
hearing would be required even on ms um
clover's case it's a discretion
and the question you have to consider is
given where you are you must hold a
hearing is what the act says there are
relevant representations following a
proper consultation period
and you are seized of the application
and
even if miss clover's right as to what
the law is following what lay calls say
it appears to suggest that there's a
discretion to hold the hearing so even
on that basis
um i say this hearing should go ahead
now um the um position to say well there
would be no right of appeal is neither
here nor there because if you come if
you decide to proceed with this hearing
and you come to a decision
then schedule five of the act applies in
the normal way you've made a decision it
is appealable within 21 days to the
magistrates courts and there would be a
de novo hearing um so um i say for all
those reasons um you should proceed to
consider the hearing i am also finally
aware that i think ms phillips your
legal adviser did
comment on the position at an early
stage and understood that the hearing
was to go ahead so as i understand it
i'm on all fours with that
madam chairman just a correction there
this wasn't a single office so within
lay calls this was the mouthpiece for
the government department
chair if i could just add on behalf of
the residents
i feel ambushed i'm not aware of any of
this before and obviously i've just
received 290 pages of of paperwork
thinking that this hearing is going
ahead i agree entirely what mr randall
tunga has said um in terms of this
hearing must go ahead today and just
disappointed obviously i understand
miss phillips may have been aware but i
certainly haven't been and feel
desperately ambushed that i'm unaware of
this and that was the position of faith
in strangers
but would support mr ranatunga's view
entirely uh go with paterson's and the
hearing must go ahead please
okay um i've consulted with our
education system we will be going ahead
um with the meeting as planned um
so moving on adam german forgive me
there there is another supplementary
point we have received correspondence um
either from miss berry or on behalf of
miss berry to indicate she won't be
making any representations to the
committee i i'd seek some clarification
on that because we did say at the
beginning the council was going to go
first that can't be right
i don't know i don't know again mrs
clover
is not making any representations she's
just introducing
who's it
madam i don't know if i can assist again
on that point um what you have
um is alison brock who is the licensing
officer in the case he's going to
present the report um and then
environmental health are here amanda
berry sits next to me she's the senior
environmental health officer who brought
the review my position i believe this
has been i represent environmental
health
my position i think this has been set
out in writing is to explain
um what the review was but also to
explain our position which is the
reasons really why we withdrew the
application
we are here um to assist the committee
nonetheless and i do hope to update you
on our position
the uh application for review remains
withdrawn it was withdrawn on the 2nd of
december but as you can well appreciate
i imagine things do move on i'm not
reinstating it in any way but i am here
to assist the committee if you have any
questions and to update them and to
explain the reasons for withdrawal
madam chair forgive me
this is very important because mr
ranatunga has just indicated that he
intends to update you
on more recent matters that that cannot
be from a legal perspective
miss berry does not have any locker
stand eye in front of the committee
because the application has been
withdrawn she didn't put in a
representation within the representation
period so technically she is not here
and although mr ranatunga represents her
he can only be her mouthpiece and
technically he's not here either
i was told in an email that she may
answer some questions from the committee
as to why the review was withdrawn but
it's still all within your agenda and if
the committee is going to be relying
upon a withdrawn
review
that has been taken away and looking at
it and looking at complaints that were
made and looking at things that were
said and looking at file notes and what
have you that again is is unlawful
because you're looking at something that
has been withdrawn from your attention
chair if i
told you if i could assist um in the
hearing rags at 17 it says members of
the authority may ask any question of
any party or other person appearing at
their hearing that's the point that's
the point she's not a party or a person
appearing
um
mr ranatunga and miss berry are here
um should it be a difficulty i will be
relying on the evidence that they put in
but my view certainly uh
representing my clients would be that
miss berry is able to speak i don't know
if mr ranatunga's got a view on that at
all
just if i may one point that we've been
clear in writing 13th of january of this
year to the premises
although the review application is no
longer being pursued the environmental
health department will be attending the
hearing to assist the committee as to
the reasons for not pursuing the
application and to explain its position
as part of explaining its position so
that i think has been made clear um and
insofar as we're present as
as under regulation 17 or otherwise
we're here to assist you
um and you did receive an application
you are seized of it it is before you
although i am not pursuing it and we
have taken a decision that we've
withdrawn it um in in so far as that's
concerned i will be if i'm given the
opportunity updating you on our current
position but i'm not pursuing the review
application um that that we put in um uh
as at um 2nd of december we indicated
that that's withdrawn
would the technical support
team manager please present the report
good afternoon this hearing has been
reconvened from the adjourned hearing
that was originally held on the 9th of
december 21. at the hearing in december
the subcommittee decided to adjourn the
meeting at the request of the barrister
representing faith in strangers so that
the matter could be considered at a
later date the subcommittee is now
requested to consider the application
and make any recommendations they feel
appropriate thank you chair
thank you
mr ranatanga would you please address
the board on behalf of the environmental
health department
up to 25 minutes
thank you madam and um
what i propose to do is just refer you
to the papers that that you had
and then update you in two respects
really the first is the reasons why we
withdrew that application it's right
that you know that and this is a public
hearing
and then to update you on any matters
arising since that in my submission are
relevant
you'll be familiar that the licensing
objectives are the matters that you must
promote in this hearing and the one that
clearly is engaged is the promotion of
the prevention of public nuisance
and um that is what under the act you
must promote which is what your decision
will ultimately be based upon i just
want to touch upon the review
application that was lodged just to give
you the background before coming to the
reasons
for withdrawal and then dealing with
other matters
i know that you will have seen a lot of
papers in this case but the review
application is at page nine
of the original agenda and you'll see
that that was lodged by amanda berry
based on the prevention of public
nuisance the grounds for review
are under pages 12
13 and 14
and it's right to note
that
what occurred here is that following the
grant of a license in august 2018 a
premises license under the licensing act
2003
environmental health received complaints
from around october 2019 and you'll see
on page 13
there was then of course covid which
intervened for a period from 2020
through to may 2021
and then further complaints received i
just want to pick out
a couple of points just to give you the
context the top of page 13
makes plain that noise complaints were
made to environmental health
five were from separate households
within cliftonville court and you'll i
hope be familiar with the area and the
surroundings
and um it goes on to say that visits in
the normal way were conducted by
environmental health and refers to
um out of hours visits
um
firstly there was a visit i think fourth
um
a planned visit on the 11th of june 2021
um then um a complainant called
the out of hours nuisance control
service on the 10th of july at around 11
o'clock
um and then noise recording equipment
was installed
and an officer assessment was carried
out on the 18th of september saturday
the 18th of september
and finally on the last paragraph on
that page a noise recorder was installed
um in september 24th to the
27th and officers were called out to
witness the noise
on days in september and october in all
instances loud music could be heard
the
application went on
um to refer to
um
a degree of entertainment music noise
from amplified equipment
and that a degree could be or had to be
tolerated to achieve a balance but that
this had gone beyond that
and what it sought
was
license conditions to be imposed on the
license and you'll see those on page 14
firstly the removal of what's known as
the live music act exemption it's only
on a review
that
you can impose noise type conditions
because of the live music act
deregulation up to 11 o'clock
for certain types of premises a noise
limiting device was suggested
and levels
were suggested up to 11 o'clock and
you'll see the first of those laq so the
level is a weighted equalized across a
period to 81 decibels
um and
just to
note that the reason why those levels
were set
um perhaps for your legal advisors note
but also for you for you madam and your
colleagues page 66
of the same bundle refers to
measurements taken at the premises
with an officer stationed in a
complainant property
and music played and they gauged the
levels that they thought would be
appropriate
up until 11 and that's why that is
included in that condition then thirdly
all live and recorded music to be
stopped at 11 pm
and all tables and chairs to have rubber
socks fitted to the legs
and to be clear on that there was an
issue with the movement of furniture and
it's right to say that the premises did
put some rubber stops on some of the
furniture
it doesn't appear to have
resolved the issues and that's why it
was included in the
review and then hand dryers not to
exceed 80 decibels la max
um and
that
was because of the noise that comes from
hair dryers
that's obviously when music was taking
place at the premises it would actually
be lower actually 55 db max
is what would be sought
as part of that condition if you if
there was no music playing so it was
conditions that were sought
and the basis for that application is as
i've outlined and you'll have seen
a number of relevant representations
that came in from others now
um
that is the um review application as was
lodged it is right and proper that i
indicate that on the 2nd of december
the 2nd of december
the environmental health department
wrote to
the premises
but also around then i think to
residents who'd raised complaints saying
that they'd taken the decision to
withdraw the application
for a licence review
now there's also in the background a
noise abatement notice that had been
issued we're not here dealing with that
and i don't wish to take up time talking
about that point but that was also
withdrawn
what was the basis for that so i need to
just explain what our reasoning was
um on further scrutiny of that evidence
which they'd gained through that
investigation
environmental health determined that the
principal reason for bringing the review
was the transfer of entertainment noise
i.e amplified music
and whilst in officers view
the impact on one of the flats now
that's flat 3
was
something that would have an impact on
the ability to sleep and therefore
clearly an issue that needed to be dealt
with
that was not considered to be a class or
community of people and therefore not a
public nuisance now
that is
a particular view taken of what public
nuisance is public must be more than one
person is the view that officers took
and
they had only been able to verify
that there was a particular issue with
one flat
and because of that
and notwithstanding that that was a real
and verified issue
um they did not feel that was public
nuisance because it didn't affect more
than one premises now i've already
addressed you on the fact that there
were complaints from i think five
different premises
the position on that is either those
other premises
um had not invited environmental health
in to verify their concerns
or if they had
what environmental health officers had
heard did not in their view constitute a
public nuisance so the levels were not
high enough to be a concern
so
those were all of the reasons as to why
environmental health took the decision
to withdraw the
application now for all the reasons i've
already outlined that application
remains before you it's been consulted
upon you've received relevant
representations you've decided to
continue as i think you must to have a
hearing to consider them
and so
the point to make here is we're now at
17th of february 2022
and things move on this environmental
health department still has a duty to
investigate complaints and it still
receives complaints
and it's right that i just update you on
that
madam chair i make a formal objection to
it it hasn't been notified i've got no
prior information as to what mr
ranatunga is about to say
he has just effectively presented the
review application to you which was
withdrawn but this is completely new and
i'm relying on regulation 18.
i'm not submitting any documents to
support this
insofar as i refer to anything
sorry
refer to anything they are letters that
the premises has received we've been
perfectly open um and they're not
without prejudice their letters in the
normal way if we receive complaints we
follow up on them and we write to the
premises and um i wish to address you on
firstly the withdrawal i've talked about
that already madam
i'm going to ask the committee to make a
formal decision about this with reasons
on the basis of regulation 18. i don't
know what letters mr ranatunga is
talking about i'm representing the
premises i haven't been put on notice of
anything additional that is going to be
presented today i know nothing about it
in terms of regulation 18 no information
and the word is information shall be
prevented presented to the committee at
the hearing if it hasn't either been
notified in advance
or with the consent of all the parties
and i don't consent
mr ranatonga if i could assist that
correspondence actually in my bundle the
letters to amanda berry on the second of
so it is in front of the committee
so the letters have been mentioned but
the details the letters haven't been
discussed so it doesn't fall under
section 18 so that doesn't
fulfill of section 18. i don't know what
he's going to say so i can't answer that
well the answer there is hear what i
have to say if there's still a concern
you can take a view and miss clover i'm
sure we'll make the point
mine yes go ahead
um the environmental health department
um in its withdrawal
letter um which i've already referred to
actually said
given evident disturbance experience by
arguments within flat 3 we sincerely
want to find a solution and ultimately
that's what the licensing act is about
and they said that even in the same
breath of saying we withdrawing the
application for the reasons we've
outlined they did say we want to find a
solution there have been um three
further letters sent to the premises
um which
um raised concerns um and the first is
the 13th of january 2022
sent to the premises can't be any
prejudice in relation to that
um and it makes clear that
as we understood it the hearing was
going ahead we had a duty to investigate
noise complaints and we asked the
premises to address the hand dryers
issue the movement of furniture
details of the acoustic consultant that
was engaged
consider installing a sound limiting
device
all of those were points that had been
raised already and we say just needed to
be dealt with the second
letter which we sent
31st of january 2022
and further to the letters of the 2nd of
december which was the draw one and the
13th of january we requested an update
on what steps were being taken to
minimize noise transmission to residents
in the adjoining cliftonville court
and
it advised specifically that
environmental health had received two
further complaints about noise from the
premises on the evening of saturday the
29th of january
um the complainants the complaints came
from separate households on the fourth
floor of cliftonville court
although the complaints were not
substantiated by council officers i they
can go in at the time and say this
definitely happened
i'm deeply concerned says amanda berry
um that noise may be now pervading into
four full fats and ask you to ensure
that the levels previously recommended
are not exceeded
and then the final letter is the 9th of
february 2022
um headed ongoing noise complaints
further to my most recent letter
so
um
31st of january i'm writing to update
you regarding complaints as you're aware
complaints have been made to
environmental health in relation to
saturday the 28th it says but it should
be the 29th of january residents were
offered available services to enable
their complaints to be investigated
further noise recorders and measurements
were taken from within three flats on
the second fourth and fifth floors on
saturday evening the measurements
suggest noise levels were well in excess
of those previously recommended i'm just
pausing there there were levels in the
review application which i've referred
to the 81 db which were those that were
measured the measurements suggest noise
levels were well in excess of those
previously recommended around 18
decibels louder with low frequency base
music plainly audible in a fourth floor
bedroom and just perceptible in the
fifth floor
um i appreciate you will not be formally
responding to this information at this
stage but want to keep you appraised of
further information and just pausing
there that's really what i'm doing
these things do move on it is right to
say and it's formally correct we
withdrew the application but i'm here to
assist you and to update you on the
current position and it is right to say
that following the withdrawal we've sent
three further letters and had no
meaningful response the response we've
had from the premises
is to say um that they've taken legal
advice and they won't be engaging with
us for all the reasons that i think ms
clover has outlined um
i'm here to say that environmental
health notwithstanding that withdrawal
have received complaints
remain concerned there is fundamentally
an issue with noise from this premises
that needs to be addressed you may feel
i'm not pursuing the review application
but in assisting you i wish to draw all
of this to your attention
thank you mr rowan
um
mr rhys gay do you have any questions
for mr ranatanga
i just wondered was there a reason why
another german wasn't sought rather than
just withdraw because obviously the
sentiment of the residence was
you know it was never discussed i just
wondered if there was
any light could be shed on that at all
i think that i think the decision was
taken
um having reviewed the evidence as they
had it at the time that
it didn't constitute public nuisance and
the other evidence that was there did
not engage that and therefore was
withdrawn
thank you
and i suppose a rather pointed question
obviously
my clients came to you in good faith um
obviously you are the responsible body
uh for dealing with noise um and yet it
was withdrawn i don't think at any stage
you were told you couldn't go into other
areas within the development as it were
um is there any reason obviously that
that wasn't done obviously these guys
understand that they were the focal
point as the head of resident
association at that time obviously off
of their flat was there any reason
obviously is that that issue that can't
quite be understood
um so my instructions are that some we
did follow the normal procedure by which
we
um did um
uh say that we could visit some of the
residents
some took that
invitation up some didn't and
certainly flat 3 we did
i think there were others but there were
others who didn't take up that
invitation and those that um did take up
the invitation apart from flat 3
we did not think the levels were such as
to engage the public nuisance licensing
objective which left us with flat three
which is one property and therefore in
our view as at the second of december i
should be clear as at the second of
december 2021 we did not feel
that that constituted a public nuisance
thank you
okay
sorry
i said okay um do any of the residents
who submitted representations have any
questions for mr ranatanga
i'm just mindful that when we say that
the call-out service was available to
other residents
that that was made available to other
residents in september
and that
i think it was withdrawn the following
month due to budgetary constraints
so
and could we identify who's speaking
please oh i'm sorry i'm i'm beth
pritchard i'm the resident
sorry
i'm chair of the residence association
and i'm also a resident of flat three
which is the most affected flat
amanda perry environmental health
officer um i believe
it was at the nuisance call out service
was also issued to two other
flats in august
and to clarify
um craig mckinley
thank you madam chairman i'm here on
behalf and probably appointed by
charlene bryant of number one yeah if i
could ask mr ranatonga the abatement
notice that was properly served on the
21st or 23rd of september 21 is page 71
in the pack
i didn't quite get the reason as to why
that was withdrawn because the the
issuance of that and the proper service
would have given you quite a number of
powers uh
not least um under the obviously the
environmental protection act to take
call to action why was that withdrawn
thank you so just to be clear that was
also withdrawn
by the letter on the 2nd of december
2021
um
we're not formally here dealing with
that but i will address it because of
the question that's been asked
you may be familiar under the
environmental protection act 1990 one of
the matters that you have to consider i
mean firstly there's an obligation to
consider whether or not there is a
statutory nuisance and officers felt
there was but in making that decision
you do have to consider what's known as
best practical means and all of the
various circumstances surrounding an
individual premises that's the
location character of the area and also
the background and the background in
this case includes a planning permission
which was granted
and a sound insulation condition
and the history which you'll probably be
hearing about but is in the papers about
it being a nightclub in the past
as well as the levels observed by
officers
um and all of those matters
should have been taken into account when
the decision was taken to issue the
noise abatement notice
some of them were not
and so the decision was taken on the 2nd
of december to withdraw that as well
that's not to say
that under the 1990 act we still don't
have a duty to
consider the position on an ongoing
basis but um
there is no noise abatement noticed
before
in existence
do any other residents have any
questions
may i make one more observational
question um because i asked just the
confirmation that the call out service
what time it closes
the nuisance control service
typically operates from around june
through to november mid of
mid-november and it when it when it's in
operation it's from 7 pm until midnight
on a friday and a saturday evening
i only raise that question because being
a nightclub often the noise is loudest
after midnight
which is part of the reason why
residents may not have called out the
service
thank you
yes i'd like to oh this is jacqueline
davis flat
owner occupier
um
you say the service was withdrawn what
about the residents
side of this
you know i mean a public nuisance is a
public nuisance which i don't think is
the building not one flat per se is not
a public
sorry
i've been
there any other questions for residents
obviously not at the moment thank you
um does mrs clover um have any questions
for mr aranatanga
yes thank you mum
just picking up on the points you've
made about the noise abatement notice um
mr ranatunga you've indicated
that environmental health are under a
continuing duty
to investigate noise nuisance but the
reasons for the withdrawal of the noise
abatement notice you've indicated as
being at least threefold
one being the grant of planning
permission
the second being the history
including frank's nightclub and the
third being best practical means those
are not going to change are they
well um
the grant of planning permission in the
history
are both um aspects of best practicable
means
but
officers have a continuing duty to
investigate noise complaints in their
area
and if they form the view that something
amounts to a statutory nuisance and that
best practical means is not
in the event available they can still
issue a notice it's not something i wish
to
constrain
for anyone any future officer seeing it
as they see it the fact of the matter is
they have to be taken into account
that's not the same as saying they
always indicate the same outcome
just to be absolutely clear about what
we mean by best practicable means under
the 1990 act that is to say that the
premises have done everything that they
can
yes
yeah and the first thing to say is
in terms of um statutory nuisance moving
forward it obviously will depend on the
level of noise that's observed and
in updating you i have indicated that
what officers have observed is higher
levels than they had observed back in on
the 2nd of december
but secondly just to come directly to
the question best practical means
um
it's everything that the premises could
reasonably be expected to do there is
that sense of it looking at all the
facts and circumstances and those
circumstances include the grant of
planning permission
and the history which is right to say
are facts in the in the background but
that does not mean if the level changes
or if the premises are not doing things
to help themselves that we couldn't on
another day in principle issue an
abatement notice but i'm not going to
constrain officers seeing it as they see
it moving forward
i don't agree with you on a number of
those points in relation to bpm
including the history of the planning
permission but that may well be a matter
for another day but i i will correct it
as i go
uh you have effectively mr ranatunga
just presented the review application
to the committee and that's noted
you have also presented an update which
was not um
foreshadowed in any way can i just
confirm that you on behalf of
environmental health or ms berry or
anybody else have not submitted
to this committee
the letters that you have just referred
to
before the committee or any details of
site visits
any measurements or any of the other
information that you have orally
presented to the committee today
so um
i don't accept um
the fact that i presented the review
application i hope it's clear and i will
reiterate this
the application itself is withdrawn it's
not pursued but it's right that you know
the background
and the reasons why
the environmental health department
withdrew its application on the 2nd of
december
in explaining that to you i have had to
go into the background and what the
review application was about
and then
in my respectful submission it's right
that we as an environmental health
department
update you as to what the position is
today and i haven't said anything other
than
um
the application is withdrawn i'm not
pursuing it
but environmental health we do have
concerns about noise from these premises
looking at what's happened since
um it is right to say
um i do not have those letters in this
bundle but they are all that i've read
from them letters that have been sent to
the premises
and there really cannot be any objection
any proper objection to that
there is a strong objection i'm just
clarifying that the environmental
department did not seek to put them
before this committee
and so far as these proceedings are
concerned that was an ambush
no answer thank you
can i clarify this the environmental
health department whether this officer
or her predecessor who as i understand
it was her managerial superior mr brown
uh looked at the application for faith
in strangers both for the license
application
and the planning permission in 2018
and together with the premises
through pre-application process and
thereafter
designed
the acoustic attenuation that was to be
put into faith in strangers
designed the condition
to go into the planning permission to
support it and thereafter signed it off
as acceptable
sorry um you're supposed to be asking
questions and not making representations
you'll have an opportunity to make your
representation shortly that was a
question
i can take quick instructions and answer
the question um
um it's right to say i think it's mr
brown
who has since left the council
was involved um both in the planning
application and the licensing
application and did make comments on
that but not miss berry who sits next to
me
just just one more question if i may
what is it that the environmental health
department are before the committee
asking them to do
today
i think it's right to
just um be as clear as i can on that
because we were clear in our letter of
the 13th of january we will be attending
the hearing to assist the committee as
to the reasons for not pursuing the
application and to explain our position
i am not pursuing
the review application
um but clearly you have a hearing where
you're going to hear from a number of
people who want steps to be taken but i
am not asking you
to take any steps
because of the position that i've
explained
thank you madam chair thank you
do mr randall mr duffy and mr ford have
any questions for mr ranatanga
um do members of the committee have any
questions for mr ranatanga
okay so this is the point of the meeting
at which members of the public who have
submitted representations will get the
opportunity to present their case
i would ask that members of the public
try to avoid repetition of points made
by previous speakers when addressing the
committee
mr risque
um please present your case as legal
representative of the residents who have
submitted representations up to 25
minutes chair thank you obviously in
terms of the time frame i'll desperately
try and stick within that i may wobble
over but i believe miss clover may ask
for extra time as well
just to make you aware so chair i act
for um georgina wilson powell uh beth
pritchard and the residents association
uh and seven members uh at the
cliftonville court uh as listed and set
out on page 107 of your papers
uh the residents occupy the flats
directly above faith in strangers
and live
across all of the four floors uh within
the block flat and i would say they are
very much a community
so in my presentation i'm going to
follow the following cover the following
eight points uh background information
uh the supporting evidence the residence
um to address you to hear first hand but
i'll probably do that at the end now
i'll move it so it's a little more
succinct the eho position which has been
summarized um
the response to uh by
faith in strangers a summary of the
current position
uh public nuisance and the guidance and
then the outcome
so in terms of ease i'll speak on the
main agenda pack and then their
supplementary agenda packs one through
to three that you've uh been given so by
way of background information
um if i could please turn you up to page
one host 107 of the the main bundle
all of the members of clifton courtville
court uh that you see here today
and i've submitted representations
eight in total
we say very much are a community um it
has been affected by the operating faith
in strangers to such a degree that a
clear public nuisance we say has been
ongoing is still ongoing and causing
them all substantial disturbance uh and
loss of private amenity
uh importantly within those
representations you'll see in the bundle
um i don't represent them but there's
one on page 100
which is not from a clifton court
resident so this is from one dolby
square which is over the road and this
evidence relates directly to the issues
from increased noise on the street late
at night between zero two hundred and
zero two thirty uh from faith and
strangers
uh should be noted uh and i set out on
page 108 uh that my clients had had eho
not launched this review then they would
have done it themselves
for clarity and as as is stated my
clients have lived in the flats for over
two and a half years which was prior to
the nightclub opening okay
and that for clarity is not they were
there two and a half years before the
nightclub opened they were there for two
and a half years which happened to be
before the nightclub opened
however five of the residents in the
cliftonville courts who have submitted
representations have lived there for
many years uh you'll see at page 94 an
occupier that's jackie
in flat 11 has been there for 20 years
and indeed similarly on page 98 shows
that there's been an occupier there for
for 50 years
uh importantly it cannot be claimed that
faith in strangers was there before the
residence
[Applause]
prior to the nightclub opening yeah it
was felt by all the residents of the
cliftonville court that it was a
peaceful residential area and a lovely
place to live
some 10 months ago now faith and faith
in strangers changed its business model
from a private member's co-working space
to a nightclub
uh it's essential to know the operation
was granted planning permission and a
premises license after the authorities
were told it would trade as a private
members club and again if i could turn
you up to page 118
of your pack
uh and it states i'm reading from the
very first line uh the space will
provide a place for free freelancers
small businesses and entrepreneurs to
rent a desk on an ad hoc basis or
permanent basis and then relax in the
evening with their guests we'll enhance
and celebrate margate's art and cultural
scene by hosting arts performance and
dining events entry to the workplace and
establishment will only be granted to
fully registered members
signed in guest members and temporary
members ticketed in particular in
relation to public nuisance and that's
three pages on on page 121
it goes on to state as the space is a
members-only location with guest sign-in
system anti-social behaviour is not
anticipated nor any late night
disturbances any performances will take
place at the furthest point from the
above residence towards the ethelbert
terraced road
the above is again echoed uh in the
covering letter for the licensing
application found on page 122
just that's the page over
our clients have no objection um
sorry and again this is summarized
on page 128 which is the actual public
notice that went up back in 2018 and
that reads flying colors will offer
a social space for members and their
guests to relax during evenings and
weekends a provision of hot food
beverage art and live performance
screenings and academic talks will form
the mainstay of our entertainment and
cultural program
so on that basis for the planning and
licensing there was no mention of a
nightclub yes the hours
were granted but that was for those
elements to take place for private
members not for a nightclub is what we
say
our clients have no objection to the
private members co-working space
or the style of operation that was
mentioned in that application
however things have changed at the
premises and it clearly has become a
nightclub
there is no disputing the premises does
now operators nightclub uh it is not
denied in its witness statement um at
all in fact in faith and strangers
the advertising of dj knights can be
found in the pack at page 43-45
of the additional document agenda pack
supplementary gender pack 2.
the premises has also been reviewed by
dj magazine
an article
titled 10 new clubs opening in 2021
and this is gender pack 3 pages 20 to 22
where it states the venue is a technic
technological mast
marvel function 1 and full fat sounds
light and an insulation
react
installation that reacts to cloud
activity crowd activity
in the supporting emails and again in
supplementary agenda pack 2 at page 175
it does confirm that dj's come across
come across from the country sorry come
from across the country uh and around
the world to play faith in strangers
at page 58 of the supplementary agenda
documentation from the resident shows
that faith in strangers uh linked to
clilch audio
whose strapline is pissing off the
neighbors since 1964
1946 so is that that type of mindset
what has the change meant then to the
residents so most weekends are now
midweek because it started on a
wednesday public nuisance is created as
a result of the playing of music uh from
the premises from seven o'clock from 9pm
the base can be felt traveling through
the building and it's possible to hear
song melodies and actual lyrics
noise becomes louder and creates more
disturbance as more
more revelers enter the premises as a
result residents of the flats cannot
relax and enjoy a normal home life
even watching telly has become near
impossible in some of the flats
it's not just the noise traveling
through the building but it's an
increase in the drunken cheering
whooping um whilst dancing and the
revelers as they enter and exit access
[ __ ] the premises residents have been
disturbed by revelers ringing their
intercoms
which are on the side trying to access
the club at all times
in addition noise from the scraping of
the furniture and the use of the
electrical hand dryers
in the toilets can also be heard
as a result of this the residents of the
flats are regularly complaining to the
environmental health department as you
have heard
eho advised that a sound diary be kept
which it was and which can be found at
pages 115 and 116
of your main agenda pack
if i could please turn you up to that
so this this came from uh
georgina's and best flat
uh and i suppose obviously it's two
pages worth but interestingly to note
that those in yellow
um
[Music]
were issues when the abatement notice
was in place and indeed those in red
when this review had been launched
so this highlights that against the
backdrop of what was a noise abatement
notice uh again we've heard that this
has been withdrawn and a review
this only being heard now the instances
of nuisance have not reduced uh they've
become more frequent and more impactful
to those that have made representations
most importantly there's been no
meaningful action to mitigate the noise
nuisance and as you'll see from page 55
of the resident's additional material
faith in strangers
is not currently corresponding with the
residents i believe that's because of
legal instruction
this nuisance uh has become so
significant that georgina and beth have
slept in a campervan on weekends and
indeed have looked to rent alternative
and have rented alternative
accommodation and have lived with
georgina's mother for a period
and will remain there until this matter
is resolved
in terms of the evidence of these issues
from the rev
residents it can be found at pages 115
and 116.
if you then turn please to
page 13 and that goes back to eho's
papers
just to highlight the salient points
so it's not just the residents saying it
so in the review papers
it confirms complaints stated in october
2019 importantly it states five were
from separate households with
cliftonville court as one of the
residents association
uh my clients at that time weren't the
head of the cliftonville court residents
association
clearly showing um contrary to what ah
stated that it cannot be that it can't
show community impact we say that it can
show community impact
eho again at page 13 confirm that
complain complaints of loud music
and patron patron noise it confirms that
specialist noise recording equipment and
outbound noise control services
from eha
were fitted
page 13 also clearly confirms that
georgina's ambassador there was clearly
a nuisance
on seven separate occasions and i set
out loud music could be heard from
within the components flat and
considered to be a nuisance
on page 14
uh it goes on to state it is evident
that the sound insulation proposed and
agreed in the original planning
application has not achieved the desired
outcome
turning you up and just so that you get
a flavor of those reports
because we feel it is important so if i
turn you first up to to page 36 that's
the actual noise log
that eho kept
page 38 on the 10th of july
there was an audible dance music with a
sound of of people noise
at 23 22 at states i went into the
second bedroom and the noise level was
considerably louder at 23 27 i could
hear chanting of it's coming home
obviously the euros were on then
um
and then it says in my opinion
it would disturb sleep and prevent sleep
especially in the second bedroom so it's
that level
page 41.
[Applause]
and that's the fourth of september
uh the use of hand dryers uh in the
premises were also audible the music
became louder and singing could be heard
but not a level of where
you could distinguish the words this was
from a dj sound system
page 42 it continues i turned the tv up
to a reasonable level and the bass was
still audible over the tv when leaving
the flat it was noted the music was
audible
in the in the communal hallway i feel
the noise level
uh would affect sleep
page 43
uh a queue of people waiting to enter
the dj was playing disco type music a
whining noise could be heard from the
hand drying machines in the toilet
importantly eho at this time visited
another flat that evening
and we now know that that's flat one and
it states the layout of this flat was
slightly different we entered the lounge
where we could hear the music a drum
beat from below
however not as bad we could not go into
the baby's room as he was sleeping it
was explained he's often woken by the
shouting and music from downstairs
continuing on page 44
they put the tv on at sound level 8
which is substantial for a small flat
and the beat from downstairs could be
heard
when we left we walked to the front of
the building where there's a queue had
grown possibly 25 waiting to enter
this is then supported um specifically
on page 46 with the actual readings and
i'll just highlight a few at certain
times so on saturday the 18th
i'm sorry at 23 12 on the friday the
17th i'm every woman lyrics discernible
saturday the 18th 1952
uh singing from customers at the balcony
2322
louder again intrusive bass beat around
33 decibels 23.41
music would disturb sleep at 29 decibels
we're already over that 23.50 hitting
levels of 38 decibels that's seven
decibels higher
and then zero zero twenty six
somebody tell me song being
can be discerned
uh zero zero fifty two madonna like a
prayer thumping noise extremely
intrusive
at points reaches 39.4 decibels that's a
good 10 decibels over
pages 50 and 51 the noise recorded
transcriptions from the 24th and 27th
are very similar again late hour0106
music level at 31db bassy and intrusive
0224
hollering and whooping from patrons i
want your love lyrics audible zero 307
furniture being moved
so not only has the night gone they've
been disturbed with that and then
there's the clear up afterwards
page 55
on the 9th of october visit
based on this evening the level of music
was significant intrusion on the use and
enjoyment of the complainant's home
page 58
the letter from eho to faith in
strangers clearly states we received a
complaint from at least one resident in
the area who claims they've
been caused a public nuisance by your
premises
page 62 and this is a letter from
christopher brown
right for information we have now had
six complaints from separate households
based on a visit of myself and my
colleague we both concluded that now
opening a statute nuisance was being
caused patient noise is certainly an
issue and has been noted on a number of
occasions
chair that was just to give you a feel
of of what these guys and some of the
residents um have put up with and
obviously that's not just them saying
them that is the environmental health
officer going to their flat and seeing
that the point is obviously that they've
made
yes it was specific to that flat and
that's what i read out but i also read
out the snippets that they were aware of
other residents being affected and
that's to my community point so then
just to turn you up specifically to to
what the other residents have said
um
correspondence that's com contained in
supplementary agenda pack one confirms
for that donna walker unfortunately she
couldn't be here today uh was writing to
the aha to say that they were being
affected so pages 14 to 20
is that correspondence between donna
walker and amanda berry in relation to
noise issues
both from loud music and loud patrons so
it's not just this flat others are doing
it page 26 to 27 is a text message from
jackie so that's jackie sat here on the
top floor flat 11. she confirmed that on
saturday the 4th of december 2021 so
that's after
the 2nd of december when it's been
withdrawn she said they've really turned
it up almost like a celebratory salvo
and again that's in your pack
page 29 confirms that complaints
um continue to be reported to eho and
that music was now being played
on a wednesday so meaning now that three
out of the seven so that's wednesday
friday saturday
and now being ruined and again
an email on the 16th of december this
can be found at page 36.
these concerns about wednesdays
are also confirmed by donna so it's not
just these guys confirming that donna
walker's also confirmed it
and the high volume and it's much higher
volume than it used to be
and we would say obviously that was due
to the
seasonal lack of action that was being
taken
another resident rosie um who's who's up
with her children on the third floor
page
49 um on the 29th of january stated it's
never been this loud my fall my floor is
vibrating and again all of that is in
the papers there
um
i was going to get the residents to
speak now but i'll wait just for
consistency to get them to speak uh
individually later so in terms of the
eho position obviously you've heard they
have withdrawn it
um the point that we would like to make
in terms of of the residents and beth
has already tried to say it that there's
only an eho call-out service that only
operates between june and november and
only on a friday and saturday night and
only until midnight obviously we're
dealing with a nightclub that operates
through till 3am on a friday and
saturday and that's in december and as
you're now aware january from the
representations and it's you know to get
that evidence that's needed in terms of
uh formally it it can't be done and
therefore the residents are hamstrung
currently at the moment
we therefore say obviously on the
evidence that i've just given you that
there is
and continues to be a public nuisance
so
from my clients perspective indeed from
the flat residents they were and are
bitterly disappointed the eho did
withdraw their representation from their
point of view as residents and a
resident association when they went with
their issue
they hoped as a
as a local authority body that they
would obviously get the evidence that
they required to deal with these issues
you know if it meant that they had to to
speak to another neighbor who'd already
complained that then that should have
been done and you know to have the
whirlpool that sorry the rug pulled from
underneath us uh back in december
was heartbreaking obviously living with
this and then obviously it getting worse
so at no stage prior to the review being
withdrawn did eho allude to the fact
that there would be issues with only
taking reading from my clients flats
other residents would have allowed
recordings to take place
if this is what the council believed is
required and we understand that they are
now doing that which is brilliant
we are not of the same view
uh
we believe that there was a a public
nuisance at that time anyway and that
would the
review should have been left in
as you have heard residents are still
making complaints and now fortunately uh
eho
are on board with that across the flats
and not just solely within flat three
so the response then we received 290
pages of documentation on tuesday
from faith in strangers and i'd just
like to deal with a number of points
before dealing with the main issues of
that
in relation to the letters of support we
believe that the council is quite
correct and that they're not
representations as they clearly don't
address any of the licensing objectives
they are purely letters of support
paragraph 18
of the witness statement on page nine
uh and that's in your supplementary
agenda pack two states that they have
uh letters of support from the local
councillors and i would urge the
committee to read these carefully and
indeed if i could turn that turn you up
to those
so it starts at page
29 and this one's from from alan curry
uh it states that they have
uh left of support sorry
it states council curry asked that
everyone
every avenue be explored to prevent the
venue from losing its music license the
premises wouldn't survive without it
but he was being informed that the
soundproofing has been installed to the
specification required which has meant a
particular business plan has been
followed
it also states that he believes that the
owners are willing to make improvements
to reduce any noise issues affecting
residents uh who live in the block above
i'm not sure that last sentence has rung
true in terms of page 30
and miss
mr yates
his email was deemed deemed support if
you read it in detail
it just confirms that and he states
information provided about f1 sound and
f1 acoustics is information he has been
told to be true although he hasn't seen
the evidence with his own eyes he also
states he is a member of the workplace
so there'd be a conflict of interest
there anyway in terms of
councillor keane on page 31
[Applause]
it confirms the business have told them
that they've complied with the sound
proofing condition
but but a late license is a necessity
for the business
some residents have written two
so some of the residents have written to
these very same counsellors and as can
be seen on page 15 of our supplementary
agenda pack three um it's been confirmed
that councillor curry was sorry to hear
that the issues um were ongoing but he
unfortunately had no jurisdiction uh on
how
faith and
strangers ran their business
on page 11 then and moving on back to
their statement
it states in our planning and licensing
application reference has been made to
music being played most frequently on
friday and saturday nights
thus 34 out of 24 weeks is not as
out of step with the original
application what we would say about this
is what is out of step is that the
planning and licensing application
didn't state there was for a nightclub
uh it stated it was for a private
members club
only
pages 13 and 15
discuss the sound system
specifics
it states that it's a domestic
hi-fi system
and that is akin to a large domestic
domestic stereo system this is in
contrast to the dj magazine article that
i've already referred you to that states
there is a function one and full fat
audio sound system
i'm not a speaker expert and maybe miss
berry might be able to comment but it
being reported in dj magazine i presume
that it's not just a domestic hi-fi
system
in summary i suppose it's quite telling
out of the 290 pages that there are in
in their paperwork 25 pages touch on
noise at the basis of this actual review
so in particular page 18 in terms of
best practical means and that's already
been discussed at states pagoda 41 sets
out elements of work that were
undertaken to meet planning conditions
it is referenced on a number of times
within their supporting paperwork
including their revised operating
schedule page 214 uh and in doubt and
indeed in their sound management plan
of august 2021 uh on page
223 i'm just turning up to that on page
223 just to give you context certainly
um for
beth and georgina
the area obviously highlighted in blue
is is where they do have sound attention
attenuation works however the other area
around it all of this area has no no
sound attenuation at all so it's
literally just specific whereas sound is
bouncing around all of these other areas
and that's all the planning condition
focused on
uh i still do have a fair bit to go
chair but as as discussed miss clover's
also got a long time as well
so following on from that chair faith in
strangers it seems are of the opinion
that they can meet their planning
conditions but somehow it's then okay to
create a public nuisance
uh as we're aware from page 14 it
clearly states from environmental health
it is evident that the sound insulation
proposed and agreed in the original
planning application has not achieved
the desired outcome in our view there
are clearly structural issues and with
sound transfer through the building from
faith in strangers
that clearly have not been addressed
most noticeable in the faith in
strangers
had a noise assessment carried out in
october 2021
and indeed by a professional but this
hasn't been seen and none of the
findings from it
have ever been circulated
there's no correspondence in the faith
and strangers documentation to show how
they're working with eh
and importantly their neighbours to deal
with these noise concerns and i think
that's been reiterated by what you've
heard this morning
instead there are 178 pages of support
letters
these
having read them say what a perfect
workplace it is and a very high level
office environment some do touch on
supporting dj led knights the issue that
we say on this
is that it doesn't deal with
the matter in hand the noise
and it doesn't mention the licensing
objectives cynically one might say that
they'd lobbied all the people that used
their own offices
the remainder of the documentation
relates to the benefits of live music to
the economy and the importance of live
that live music is being overlooked
no one would disagree with that and
that's the that's why there is
no one would disagree with the
importance of live music and that's why
there is the live music act
and it allows live and recorded music to
take place between the hours of zero 823
for up to 500 people if the premise has
a license however should you wish to
carry out
live or recorded music after that you
need to apply for your authorization
that is the crux of why we're here today
that you should should you choose to
operate outside of those hours uh you
need to do so without creating a public
nuisance and indeed be accountable for
that operation
paragraph 46 uh the faith in strangers
witness statement is particularly
telling and indeed explains why the
focus of the documentation is not
on how issues are not focused on how
issues can be resolved but is the main
reason why
they should be allowed to keep their
later hours at states and if i could
turn you to it it's page 20 uh in
supplementary agenda pack 2.
it's patently clear that for the
organization to be economically viable
busy friday and saturday nights with
music and dancing
are what generate revenue the money
generated by the creative workspace is
an ancillary to the main source of
income while sadly people do not tend to
spend money when attending spoken word
poetry nor academic talks these are lost
leaders for the business this statement
also clearly explains the focus of why
the documentation relates to the live
music
it could not be clear that the operators
of faith in strangers have decided that
income generation outweighs the needs of
the local residents in the flats above
and this is the reason why they continue
to play loud music until late into the
night causing hardship and distress to
the flats
indeed this rings true with what i've
already said council of curry's emails
saying preventing the venue from being
allowed to play music from 11 p.m would
mean that the venue would not survive
financially or in its present form and
indeed councillor keane reiterated the
same
stating a late license is a necessity
for the business
it's telling that there's no denial that
noise concerns exist for the residents
just that because they have met the
planning condition for a co-working
space that they can operate as they wish
much has been made of franks as well in
terms of history but just to bear in
mind that shut in the early 2000s almost
some 20 years ago so
in terms of time frames just so that
you're aware
so in terms of
a position from the evidence that you've
heard
orally and indeed in writing it's clear
that the issues continue
there is public and statutory nuisance
taking place
as a result of their operating style
complaints have been ongoing for two
years
and still matters not being resolved and
have been no attempts by the premises
license holder to meet with residents to
explain future operations and how indeed
they will deal with the issues
rather an attempt to mitigate the
problems the opposite has been the case
seeking to operate on wednesdays as well
as weekends in order to adhere to their
business plan
as well as the issues from noise from
music they're issues from noise from
revellers
entering an accident they're curing
furniture
and
indeed the hand dryers
so where does that leave us in terms of
public nuisance uh the guidance and the
statement of licensing policy
this is all covered
uh specifically and paid on page 110 of
your big public agenda pack uh but just
to read the the salient points
um and i'll start with paragraph 11.1
the proceeding set out in 2003 act for
reviewing premises license represent a
key protection for the community where
problems associated with the licensing
objective occur after the grant of a
variation of the premises license and
that's exactly where we are today
215 through representations the
licensing authority can consider what
con constitutes a public nuisance and
what is appropriate to prevent it it's
important licensing authorities focus on
the effect of licensable activities of
the specific premises on persons living
and working in the area which may be
disproportionate and unreasonable
these issues mainly concern noise
nuisance light etc
216 again is very important and i'll
read that verbatim
public nuisance is given a statute
meaning in many pieces of legislation is
however not narrowly defined in the 2003
act and retains its broad common law
meaning it may include inappropriate
circumstances the reduction of living
and working immunity and the environment
of persons living and working in the
area licensed premises public nuisance
may also arise as a result of adverse
effects of artificial lives dust odor
insects or other prejudices to health
then at 2019 again is extremely
pertinent where applications have given
rise to representations any appropriate
conditions should normally focus on the
most sensitive periods for example most
sensitive people for people being
disturbed unreasonably loud music is at
night and into the early morning when
residents in adjacent properties may be
attempting to go to sleep or are
sleeping this is why there's still a
need for licence of performance of live
music between 11 pm and 8 a.m in certain
circumstances conditions relating to
noise emanating from the premises may
also
be appropriate to address any
disturbance anticipated as customers
enter and leave
this is then also reiterated and again i
obviously due to time it's set out very
clearly on page 110 and onwards but it's
also reiterated in your very own
statement
of licensing policy
just to touch on the committee will also
no doubt be aware of the
no i won't mention that
[Applause]
so in terms of
of of where the residents are um as it
were
they don't want to be overzealous at all
they're not seeking uh revocation
although we think the way that faith and
strangers have behaved decided not to
work with us
you know
the position that's been taken at this
very review we should all be working
together to make sure that this is dealt
with instead we've just got an
entrenched view that it's not us
they've got to go because we we
fulfilled our planning conditions
our view for the residents would be
we would like to seek that all
licensable activities uh finish at 2300
hours daily uh this will eliminate the
noise
created by loud music
as well as the noise from the revelers
so that's all licensable activities at
2300.
the electronic hand dryers be replaced
with towel dryers
to deal with the noise from the dryers
or an alternative be sourced that aren't
noisy
indeed all
furniture have rubber socks
as mr ranatunga mentioned that there'd
be the remove of the live music act
exemption obviously because this is a
review which deregulates live and
recorded music before 2300
and that a noise limiter be fitted and
conditioned
to the levels that are deemed
appropriate by environmental health
themselves you've also i believe set
those levels
so chair those are those are my
submissions on behalf of my clients uh
and indeed uh the residents uh and the
residents would now like to brief you
just so that you get a personal view of
where they are so i don't i don't know
if you've seen the image
faith in strangers on the second floor
and these guys are all flat above it
over four floors
so i suppose if we start with
can you stop and raise away
oh could we could we start with um
chad do you think we could start with
rosie maybe he's waiting with her
children is that all right
would you like to go now
and then she's coming in
madam chair i don't if there's any point
in me raising the fact that it was
supposed to be 25 minutes each and it
can only be people who've made a
representation in advance who can be
allowed to speak okay this is only five
minutes
come on you're ready please yes please
um so um so this is where residents have
submitted representations to address the
committee and it's up to five minutes
each
oh do i just okay
okay
i'm sorry this person hasn't made a
representation
all the flat numbers have been excised
from my bundle
um
hi
hi um rosie may
would you like to um i don't know what
i'm doing i need to like be told
sorry
of the noise okay i don't want to put
words in your mouth yeah no that's fine
um
um well obviously it's been hard um
i have a little boy that has autism um
he's three years old he
at the moment
um goes to nursery so
he's sleeping and
sorry i'm very nervous i'm not very a
confident person
um
yeah he has autism um obviously if you
look up the words autism you understand
that it's very sensitive to hearing
and noise and um feeling stuff and
um
like other things like
foods other stuff like that but it's
mainly on hearing
um in his bedroom his bedroom's directly
up above faith in strangers so when the
music's thumping through the building
you can actually feel it on the floor
um it's mainly
in the boys room than it is through the
whole
of my flat which is more concerning
because obviously it's the boys room i
also have a one-year-old as well that
sleeps in the bedroom with freddy
i obviously struggle with
mental health which doesn't help as well
so yeah i don't know i don't know what
else to say
sorry
sorry
yeah that's fine thank you rosie thank
you
um with
other residents like to um basically
representation
so
if i may um the evidence that the that
faith and strangers have put forward has
um got some personal uh
suggestions about my integrity i would
like to be able to address them after
they've been made rather than
talk about them now if that's okay would
that be possible
okay so
let me read this to you then uh my name
is beth i live directly above faith in
strangers sharing a floor with their
ceiling
my father taught me you should play the
ball not the man
it sounds like me greatly having read
the submission that faith and strangers
have decided to make
they've opted not to up to work by that
maxim and i'm now in the position where
i feel it necessary to talk about my
personal history in a licensing
committee which is here to talk about
public nuisance
by way of background i am an accountant
a charity trustee chair of cliftonville
court's residence association and prior
to the pandemic i was vice chair of key
worth primary schools board of governors
i will be glad to answer any questions
the committee has about the personal
matters raised by the licensees
suffice to say i do not recognize many
other points they make about me
whilst i do not see them as relevant to
a licensed review hearing about ongoing
noise nuisance given the picture that
has been painted of me i would be most
grateful if the committee would allow me
to clarify the following
prior to the purchase of our flats the
licensees of faith and strangers
please i just this is going to seem very
out of context um unless you've read
their submission so this i really do
apologize if this seems incredibly
irrelevant however it's been raised in
their evidence so i just want to address
it yeah prior to the purchase of our
flats the licensees of faith and
strangers also wanted to purchase it
however they could not agree on a
purchase price with the vendors
having seen the evidence submitted to
the committee by the licensees i do
wonder if this is a source of resentment
to them
that aside
we purchased our flat for 144 000 pounds
not 120 000 pounds as the licensees have
suggested
the flat was in very poor repair when we
moved in and we spent considerable sums
refurbishing it windows bathrooms etc in
total we have spent upwards of 175 000
pounds
against this backdrop the offer the
licensees and freeholder put to us to
buy our flat for 150 000 was far from
generous
the licensees also admitted to mention
that when they wrote to us about the
offer they intimated we could be open to
legal action if we raise further
complaints with environmental health
with reference to my living arrangements
i work at home in cliftonville course my
life is in margate i am registered for
the doctors and margate and pay council
tax here and recently applied to be a
local school governor
i can confirm as the pax says that i own
a flat in london i'm not sure why that
is relevant but i can also tell you that
there is a lodger living in there
i would like to apologize for the
committee for bringing such personal
masses to you
um
yeah i'm going to leave it there i'm
chair of the resident association so i'm
more than happy to answer any questions
generally about the building but i think
there are enough residents here to bring
to life um the experiences that we've
had
thank you
would other residents like to speak
yes please um
my name is georgina i also live in flat3
cliftonville court
uh immediately immediately above faith
in strangers
i run my own business it employs three
people locally and i'm the environmental
editor at the margate mercury
i bought the flat as
beth said
in we moved in in june 2019 it's my
first and only property
since may last year i've been kept awake
nearly every friday and saturday night
off until 3am or later
by wednesdays each week i dread the
weekends coming i often get home late on
a friday only to be met with bass and
patron noise so i walk in the door at
about nine o'clock
we've registered up to 50 decibels in
our flat it's impossible to do anything
normal
at gone 2am i can hear lyrics from songs
and people singing and shouting for the
dj to play longer
then we hear the cleanup which um we've
talked about which you can also hear so
sometimes it's gone three o'clock before
we can sleep in the three o'clock in the
morning before sleep is possible
the venue's cleaning staff often wakes
us up before 8am on the weekend so the
scraping furniture around the floor is
like fingers down a blackboard it's so
loud
and then it happens all again the next
night on saturday night so i spend all
day saturday dreading the repeat
and we're already tired from the lost
sleep some weekends we only get seven or
eight hours sleep over the whole weekend
this is what nearly every weekend has
been like for us month after month after
month since may and it's had a hugely
negative impact on our mental emotional
and physical health
we're stressed anxious and worried all
the time we've got no quality of life in
our flat between thursday and sunday we
can't watch tv we can't have dinner
together we can't invite people over we
can't have family to stay
it's the same for every room in our flat
and simply put the soundproofing does
not work
we've had to call out environmental
health every weekend as you've heard
when their call-out service was
available stopping our normal life in
order to gather evidence for noise
discernments that residents of this
block are victims of while then you've
been allowed to continue operating in
full knowledge of the damage they're
causing to the block
some weekends we've had to resort
leaving our home in the middle of the
night because we can't stand the noise
anymore sleeping in a camper van even in
winter
because the noise levels have increased
after the licence hearing was issued i
found it all too much in december and i
had to leave my home entirely and stay
with family for most of december
the original license hearing in december
being cancelled directly cost us a huge
amount as we had to go and rent another
flat on top of our mortgage unable to
yet face more weeks of the noise and
uncertainty and feeling under threat
from the unrepentant attitude that we've
we've been facing
it's had a wider impact as well um it's
in the man it's in the packs as well but
we've had to twice delay our ivf
treatment because the noise disturbance
caused by their events
has meant we've been unable to proceed
knowing that we can't sleep or relax at
a time when both are crucial to success
and we've also had to divert all of our
savings into these legal fees
and it's not just us
our neighbours kids have been kept awake
retired people who aren't well have been
kept awake and neighbours have left and
now avoid the building directly because
of the venue
i can't understand how we can talk about
community-minded business
while the 12 families of cliftonville
court are being driven out of the
community that's been theirs for decades
since the license review in december the
venue's got even louder but we've been
unable mostly to call our environmental
health to witness it because the call
out service isn't available
with a robust without a robust
environmental health service the need
for this license review is even greater
faith and strangers choose to be a
nightclub and they choose to have djs
and live music until 3am the residents
here haven't got a choice in this and
yet we're wearing all of the emotional
and mental and financial costs
thank you
thank you
kraven kinley
thank you very much madam chairman i'm
here on behalf of charlene bryant and as
you can imagine this is quite unusual
for an mp to be at one of these events
but this case um went over a boundary
where i felt that i really had to be
involved for so many residents
now um just going back if i can run
through some of the the notes and refer
you to some different pages on i'll
refer to the public document pack which
is obviously the only one i have
uh on page 12
when this um application was first
granted in in 2018
the application by the the applicants
was for a change of use of the first
floor from nightclub to a mixed office
and restaurant and arts venue
right so that's quite clear what they
intended uh but they were obviously
granted in august 18 a license to permit
live and recorded music
uh sunday to thursday
till 1am close and friday and saturday
and bank holiday sundays 3 a.m close
so they're technically obviously
operating within the license so they
were given but it would seem to me their
primary objective which litters through
a lot of these documents was for it to
be this sort of members club with
uh poetry and that type of thing i'm
just referring to their own document
page 118 of the public document
it says the space will provide a place
for freelancers small businesses
entrepreneurs to rent a desk
and then relax in the evenings with
their guests it will enhance and
celebrate margate's arts and culture
scene now those type of statements at
the start of when they first wanted this
place were quite clear
now i realize that when um
licenses are granted
and
drinks licenses particularly with with
times in mind they're often given by
good faith by officers with the ascent
of committees
and with the hope that that is what it
shall be
but i'm afraid things sometimes evolve
and i think that is why we're here today
now i have some disappointment uh to aim
at some of the officers of tdc because i
think the residents feel that they
haven't really been on their side all
the time they had much hope when that
abatement notice was issued they had
much hope when there was that planning
here or the licensing hearing due on the
9th of december that was then withdrawn
but you know i thank you today for what
you have been able to put into the arena
and i i really do
so it's really been left to residence to
try and bring this to
explain with some clarity to the
committee uh i i've had uh reports i
think they're probably with you from a
number of residents showing you know
just how dreadful life is that's from
donna walker from flat nine from
jacqueline davies who's here at flat 11
and of course georgina wilson powell and
her partner in in flat 3 and from rosie
may deal
now
people think mps have power we don't
have any power i'm a backbench mp
i might have influence but i have zero
power
you are the first tier tribunal today of
a licensing potential um
escalation because it could go from here
to the magistrates called you have real
power today real power
because what you are deciding today will
mean whether people can live a decent
life
just enjoying what they have and what
they've bought
maybe the primary asset they have in
life
they live there just wanting to look
over the sea and enjoy life as we all do
in our properties
and
what is happening probably the outcome
of this this hearing could actually
decide whether the asset that they they
love and have enjoyed will be worth
what they paid for it or next to nothing
it seems to me
and i had high hopes i really had high
hopes of faith in strangers based on
those statements that they gave that it
would be what it said it would be
now as part of
when they were having to go through the
sound
the sound issues
there was a mention in here that
their sound system
could could be 100 decibels
but they didn't think it would ever be
used at that level now i know hundred
decibels ten decimals what does that
mean can i just give the committee some
idea what 100 decibels means 100
decibels is a jet taking off at 300
meters
81 decibels which i think all have
appreciated might be reasonable sound
volume
each 10 decibels is a tenfold difference
so 80 to 90 that's 10 times the music
intensity and our ears record that as
twice the volume
so 80 to 100 is a hundred times the
sound intensity and four times the real
volume on our ears now we've had a lot
of noise recording and that starts from
page 45 onwards
and it's been pretty grim reading
frankly
um no sorry we had a number of noise
records i think from page 100
so many here
108 onwards yeah the various uh noise
recordings have taken place at strange
times of day and it seems to me
after 11 o'clock
the noise has gone up
not down it's actually gone up at
exactly the time when people like
rosie may deal's children are trying to
go to sleep when other people are trying
to get a night's rest so they can go to
work the next day that is when the noise
has actually gone up
i'm just getting started but uh no i i'm
trying to
just amplify some of what uh mr rhys gay
has said
but as i say i wouldn't be here unless i
was concerned i mean what are we now two
hours of an mp's time to look after 12
residents when i've got a hundred
thousand people to look after and in
this constituency that is the reason i'm
here because i take this very very
seriously
now i cannot leave you with one last
thing about the intents of this place
i looked at their website just this
afternoon before coming
they've got an event on
on saturday the 19th of february that's
advertised on their website
and they've got a guy coming called
james thompson
and just reading about this event
i mean this is after they've had a noise
abatement notice cherry you're going to
allow this to they have noticed about
this meeting today
it's on your website so i don't think
it's private can i just read it it's a
timing issue can i just read their
advertising
i'm here as a resident not as an
official legal advisor
can i just say as in my closing
statement
about james jim jimmy the artist
formerly known as jimbo whatever you
know him by if you know you know this
guy has been has been setting trends i
think he's going to say has set trends
and making taste from before you were
born join him on saturday this is this
saturday as we collectively get our
boogie on and tear the roof off
i think that's what this place intends
to continue thank you madam
chairman thank you
are there any other residents that would
like to talk
madam chat again i'm really really sorry
could we have a comfort break please
we've been going for quite a long time i
was going to have one at four o'clock
which is um in ten minutes i think some
people can't wait that long
okay so everyone happy for a comfort
break now
that's fine we've only got three to go
please thank you
we have 10 minute break
welcome back everybody
um
so
are we gonna continue now with the
residents um representation thank you
as before good afternoon i'm jackie
davis flat 11 owner occupier um i have
lived i'm in my 80s which is a
consideration you want your sleep when
you get older
the noise
it's not every night and all the time
but when it does come through it
permeates through the building through
the
vents etc you know it's really really
bad um i've got an ongoing neurological
disorder it's called gill and barry in
case you're interested but it's i'm in
recovery from it but it's still evident
and it's not conducive with the noise
because you don't want peace and quiet
with these things
also
i'm on the region roster for the local
mass where i go to and i'm letting them
down a lot because you just can't get
your sleep and i need my sleep um we're
a lovely community made a lot of friends
one way and the other it is the noise
factor i'm all for
entrepreneurialism and things like that
but this is beyond the pale it really is
oh yeah so i'd like to say thank you
very much thank you
i'm reading this on behalf of um donna
walker
flat a cliftonville court
um my husband and i and our
four-year-old daughter live in
cliftonville court three stories above
faith in strangers rather than focus on
the impact on our lives which is very
similar to the others living here who
you have heard or will hear speak today
there are two key issues which i would
like to draw your attention to
one in relation to soundproofing and the
historic use of the building and the
other is in relation to noise levels
faith in strangers inhabits part of the
old frank's nightclub which closed in
the early 2000s four of the twelve flats
within our building have been in the
same ownership for more than 20 years
and so we know that the levels of noise
we are all experiencing today are far
greater than the levels of noise
historically generated by franxx
this is because the soundproofing
measures which frank's nightclub had
installed were all removed
my husband and i who are both architects
walked around frank's in 2016 and we
have photographs from that day
at that time the space was derelict and
parts of the ceiling had collapsed due
to water damage and so we could see the
historic fabric of the building laid
bare
firstly frank's nightclub had no windows
at all
they chose to block up all of the
original window openings and enclose the
roof terrace with dense block work
nightclubs do not generally have windows
as glass cannot stop the passage of
sound in the same way that a solid wall
can
by contrast faith in strangers interior
is light and bright with large windows
and sea views their speakers are located
within the largest of these windows
directly underneath the front facade of
our flat
furthermore the ceilings and walls
within faith in strangers have also been
stripped of their historic soundproofing
measures
frank's had a suspended ceiling
throughout dropped by around half a
meter from the floor slab above with
substantial
amounts of sound insulation and dense
plasterboarding
similarly the walls and columns were
boarded out with sound insulation all
around
meaning sound could not travel and
vibrate up through the structure of the
building
today this concrete structure is fully
exposed giving the interior its
aesthetic character with concrete
columns and force labs clearly visible
throughout
i also want to touch briefly on noise
levels the world health organization
states that sleep disturbance occurs at
noise levels above 30 decibels
the noise within our flat which is three
stories up from the venue regularly
reads well above this when measured on a
noise app and this has a detrimental
impact on our ability to sleep
faith in strangers did propose some
sound proofing as part of their planning
conditions sign off which can be seen in
annex one
the drawing here states that the sound
proofing to their ceiling will reduce
the noise by 120 to 140 decibels this
was clearly not
as not worked as intended
if sound was successfully reduced by
this amount then the flats above would
hear no noise at all as an architect who
knows the basics of soundproofing this
is no surprise to me as soundproofing
just a part of a ceiling alone will
never block the transfer of noise for
effective soundproofing you have to
create a sealed box within a box where
all of the internal linings are
physically separated from the external
structure of the building
there have been no offers made by faith
in strangers to try and improve the
sound proofing of their premises
furthermore it should also be noted that
despite environmental health setting
what their deemed to be acceptable
levels for music some time ago
these levels have been consistently
ignored and in recent months the volume
of music has got louder than it ever has
been before
i believe faith and strangers have two
choices one is to revert to their
original business plan as outlined in
their planning submission of being a
co-working space by day with quieter
arts and cultural events in the evenings
something which all of the residents
here would support
the other is to install extensive sound
proofing which would include blocking up
their windows and removing their sea
views which would then enable them to be
a late night music venue
as it currently stands their nightclub
usage at weekends is incompatible with
the space that they occupy
and also incompatible with a residential
block of flats directly above
just to say i'm on the top floor in flat
10 and i think
this is
devastating you know our community is
all i can say
it's really really upsetting
and i'm sorry for faith and strangers as
well
this feels a really sad situation
that would like to talk
i think hi um my name's trilby ryan um i
live at number four which uh
cliftonville court which is on the third
floor of the building
um i've lived in my flat ten years
and i'm a cook one of the cooks at
northbound school primary school i've
been in my job for 12 years
um
the music coming from faith in strangers
i first noticed because i could hear a
bass line going on
and when i went out and went downstairs
to investigate a nice there's a doorway
down the bottom of the building which
leads to the club and that's where the
music was coming from so then i went
back upstairs again um
i heard lyrics on at least one occasion
which was new rules you're going to miss
my loving so you can actually hear word
for word and i did think at the time
that was pretty loud but the thing that
concerns me our building's quite fragile
we're having restoration work done at
the moment
it was vibrating it makes it vibrates um
there is a thing about people to outside
of the club
um i don't know how much this is the
responsibility of the club
themselves but they did promise in their
first um like the first that now
solicitor read that there was they were
guaranteed that people wouldn't make any
noise afterwards so i'm going to leave
the car park very quietly etc on a
number of occasions because the entrance
is sort of on the corner my bedroom was
above here and i've been woken up and
had to look out and see what's going on
they've often been altercations there's
bad language smoking all sorts of things
going on and this coincides with times
when there's been late night um
dues at the club
so um uh yeah there's it is a worry too
damaged property our property has been
damaged in the past particularly the
front door may or may not have anything
to do with it but we have to pay for
those damages um the only other thing i
wanted to say was um we've just all the
residents each i'm just
sorting on but we have paid the best
part of 23 000 pounds each flat
to pay for the restoration of the
building and it's been a very stressful
thing all along this has been going on
for some time now the building work now
is going on but um
we've had enough and we we would like to
now you know we want to enjoy our homes
it grates a bit when you've paid all
that money and then
you've
you have this this disturbance from the
club um as has been said all of us were
very happy when it was advertised as an
art center we were looking forward to
going there um
the least two i would like to say just
lastly the first thing and at least the
first bit of our lease says that we are
entitled to some kind of
assemblage or quality of life and so far
with everything but especially with the
club knives we haven't we don't have
that so that's all i'd like to say thank
you
thank
thank you very much um does the
licensing team have any questions for
those representing the residents
no
okay um
does the environmental health team have
any questions no
um miss clover um do you have any
questions for those representing the
residence
mom it's not my practice uh to ask
questions uh in these circumstances can
i take it uh or
um submit it globally
to the committee that um
the submissions that have been made by
the residents are all in contention
they're not agreed but if i were to ask
questions about each and every one of
them we would be here for potentially a
long time so i'm going to leave it like
that we we disagree with the things that
have been said and i'm going to make
submissions about that
um but i won't be asking specific
questions but that is not to say that
what's been said is conceded
thank you
dismissed around mr duffy or mr ford
have any questions um for those
representing the residents no
do members of the committee um
have any questions for those
representing the residents
no questions okay
i did just want to clarify actually one
one point with the resident um because a
lot there's a lot said about frank's
nightclub and obviously frank's gone but
um there's a lot been said about
soundproofing being removed from frank's
and i had to think about the box in the
box i mean is there any any verifiable
you know evidence basically to show that
franks was actually
a quieter
venue for for the residents
than faith and strangers is
sorry we have submitted photos and i'll
try and turn those up but obviously the
elder members of the community may be
able to assist
yes i'd like to just add that i was a
resident there prior to frank's when it
was the starlight club and the noise
over the uh not over the years this is
worse than it's ever been all over the
years
so
that's all i'd like to say was respect
to everybody
so i'm not a soundproof engineer or you
know i don't understand soundproofing
but you know like um you know has there
been you know has there been you know
like um anything done to sort of like
show why the soundproofing was better
than with franks than it is now
there was a huge sort of like a whole
floor above france as far as i can see
it but the club is now in there so that
was the soundproofing i think donna and
sam who gerald read the statement from
their um like architects so they know
all about the building but the trouble
is now in where the
was i suppose and it was all brick
because i remember well when they
drilled out every window
noise was horrendous but um
i just said i'm not attacking the first
one don't know but um
donna and son could explain it but that
seems to me that that's so you're now
like absolutely next door to
um both of the floor where the flat is
you're just below somebody's floor and
chris brown
funny enough said to me um that you must
have a certain amount of meat as
between even when there's public works
going on you must have a certain amount
of distance between people because of
decibel damage to your ears
so so previously when frank's was that
frank's was a club there was like a
floor above yeah and you now have got
like residential units on the floor
above not quite the club
no no no i'm not quite but the club is
sort of where the gap used to be isn't
it really yeah
it was the same model
yeah was that's what i thought it was
just an empty yeah thing wasn't it rose
said she never had any problems from
frank's in the past i never heard much
yeah but i i think you've just got to
think of sound as the same as water you
know and
it's got to be encapsulated for it not
to vibrate and i think sam and
donna have got pictures uh to show the
difference
and yeah and how in the difference
that it was and
it does and the design i think the
design that it is went with the original
business plan you know to maximize the
windows the sea views lovely office
space that all made sense but it does
not make any sense for a nightclub and
you know i have to say i i love dancing
i love music i love but it's just not
fit for purpose it's a nightclub it
fitted the original plan and it's the
opposite
for what it you know for a nightclub
i'm in the best position but i can still
hear that because i'm right at the top
and the far back but i can still hear
the bass and if i had a shazam you know
i could get some of the music you know
the shazam that tells you
so
you know it's it's because the pillars
there's concrete pillars connecting the
whole of the building
that's the one of the main problems as
well
yeah
yeah
cut cut to the paintbrush may i just
just so there are three flats directly
above faith and strangers
mr mckinley is representing one of them
where they weren't most affected middle
flat is actually vacant um
hence why that lady isn't here she would
be very badly affected her dog used to
howl when they had events in 2019 um
she died i thought she not unfortunately
she died unfortunately just full stop
but um
um
so the reason the reason that you have
this we have from that individual is
because it's vacant flat there's another
fact that would be very badly affected
flat six that's also vacant
so yeah
that's a bit of context
also frank's was
well over a decade ago 15 years ago or
so so
a lot of people moved in and out in that
time
from what we understand um when you had
frank's
the first lot of flats basically they
were there but his staff lived in there
so they weren't actually lived in by
residents
okay thank you
hey i had that i bought the flat well my
husband and i bought the flat
while the nightclub was there because we
had friends who lived there and they
recommended it and the flat went vacant
and we took it but there was no
disturbance as such a little bit of in
the summers windows open our windows but
not like it is today definitely not so
it's a lot worse now
okay
any other questions from the committee
no okay ms clover um could you please
present your case as legal
representative of faith and strangers
yes ma'am thank you
well uh as you might imagine uh there
are two sides
to every story and and this one is quite
some story uh just with the greatest of
respect to them just to pick up on what
the residents have just said about
technical
acoustic details and
sound being like water or decibels or a
box within a box or any of those sorts
of things
may i put the committee on alert that
all of that is wrong
acoustics is a very highly technical
scientific speciality an architect is
not an acoustician
and the information that you've been
given about the difference between faith
in strangers and franks is empirically
incorrect
you do have some acoustic information in
your paperwork
i will be touching on it briefly clearly
i don't get a huge amount of time
but these matters are extremely
important uh and you will be hearing
about
how the environmental health department
of this council and i averted to earlier
not only signed off but effectively
designed
the appropriate acoustic attenuation for
faith in strangers
as it was going to be as it currently is
which takes me really to my opening
point which is it's not a nightclub
it never has been
uh it hasn't changed the business model
from what was submitted in the course of
licensing application or planning
permission application and you may note
from all the submissions you've heard
from environmental health or licensing
that they do not contend any differently
this is not
uh a trojan horse change of business
model scrabbling around at the last
minute to find a way of making money
this is absolutely
bang on point what faith in strangers
is and was and was always going to do
and what was submitted in the course of
the licensing application the operating
schedule the design and access statement
for the planning permission faith in
strangers conducted pre-application
discussions
with planning who you will note are not
here
and planning are a responsible authority
in licensing terms and could be here if
they had any concerns that faith in
strangers was exceeding its planning
permission or going in anyway
off-piste with it
faith in strangers engaged with all of
those officers to discuss their
proposals and what they were going to do
and the speaker specification and the
sound attenuation possibilities before
they took the lease
the freeholder
for the premises had been looking for a
tenant since 2016
and faith in strangers before they
decided to take up
the uh the building uh engaged with the
council and the officers to make sure
that what they proposed to do was going
to be suitable and effective and it
hasn't changed from the license
application or the planning permission
application and that is clear to see
from the wording of both and these are
both recent authorizations
we're not talking about grants that were
given many many years ago we're talking
about in the last couple of years
in the case of the
license we're talking about uh in case
of both of them we're talking about 2018
the planning permission was august 2018
and the license uh also a little bit
later in august of 2018.
so certainly uh recent now we've put in
uh on behalf of uh the mr randall mr
duffy for faith in strangers an
extensive statement of truth uh which
has the declaration of truth and has
been signed i'm not going to seek to
repeat all of that so i would ask that
you take account of all of that in your
own time um the exhibits that went with
that appear to be very lengthy they are
predominantly composed of letters of
support
of which i will be saying more in due
course um many of the the council didn't
accept the letters of support
there was over 100 of them they came in
in november faith and strangers has been
trying to get hold of them ever since
and i think we got them either on friday
or monday
and that was after we um indicated that
we were going to have to submit a
freedom of information application or an
environmental information regulations
application to get them which is quite
wrong
some of them should have been before you
in any event as relevant representations
just as these residents
many of them if not all of them should
have been before you in the exercise of
your public sector equality duty and i
will be coming back to that later
because that has not been exercised in
this case either
faith in strangers was not granted
planning permission as a nightclub and
if what the residents are saying were
correct they'd be in breach of their
planning permission and there would be
enforcement proceedings from your
planning department
and there is not
that is because they're not doing
anything wrong the work space that you
will read about in the many many letters
of support the different people who use
it in different capacities during the
day during the evening during the night
it is exactly as it was intended to be
and it has work areas within it i was
there a little earlier today it's all
set out with the the work units those
are not moved away on an evening to
create a dance floor or anything of that
sort
the the space is uh set up that the way
that it was intended to be and the many
many letters of support that you have
received and i don't know if the
committee's had any kind of realistic
opportunity to read or absorb them in
the very short time that you've had them
but bear in mind the council's had them
since november
will give you a very good flavor as to
what these premises are all about and
what they do
on a day time basis and a nighttime
basis and also importantly the value
of these premises to the community at
large
and i appreciate that the cliftonville
residents have talked about themselves
as a community
there is a wider community
that is engaged here which is very
important
so important in fact that it has been
commented upon for relevance by the
court of appeal and i will come back to
that later
as well so the two sides of this story
there was no issue
so far as the faith in strangers
proposal was concerned until ms wilson
powell and miss pritchard moved into
flat three there had been no complaints
prior to their complaint in the autumn
of 2019 shortly
after faith in strangers had conducted
some of their early
events
they have clearly been writing to the
neighbours and that is evidenced in your
pack
we've had some uh reference by mr ruiz
gay
to lobbying
if writing to people who work and use
faith in strangers is lobbying then so
is writing to your neighbors asking them
to join with you
in a campaign of complaint against the
premises it's the same thing
there were no complaints to
environmental health before the flat 3
occupants moved in perhaps more
tellingly
there was no objection to the license
which included the music
live and recorded and the speaker
specification and the sound attenuation
and there was no objection to the
planning permission application either
which is a very good indication
as to any level of concern
that residents may have had and they
will now say well everything has changed
well no
it hasn't the application set out
the specification for the speakers it
was all there
and it was assessed by the environmental
health officers who were consultees to
both the license application and the
planning application
more importantly mr ranatunga has
mentioned to you the history
of this site
uh which was relevant you know to the
noise abatement notice and whether that
could be sustained or not and the answer
was not because this was not and never
has been a tranquil residential area the
use of this area is characterized
and that's an important word in noise
nuisance
by a nightclub use for some 40
years it's the established lawful use of
the site that will pre-date most if not
all of the residents who have chosen to
live there starlight for some 20 years
frank's for 20 years after that there
were complaints about frank's that's on
record you will see within the pack that
you have in the representations that
have been made um that there's some
colloquial and anecdotal reference to
frank's and how it used to shake the
building
and you heard from your licensing
officer perhaps some of the indications
as to why there weren't more complaints
and that is because frank bought up the
flats
the flats immediately above for the use
of his
staff
now it's been suggested that some major
structural reconfiguration has occurred
between frank's incumbency and the faith
in strangers such that there was a spare
flaw
of some description absolutely not the
case at all there's been no
restructuring of that sort that there
was no noticeable
change in the structural integrity of
the building i will talk about the
attenuation
that franks had however because that is
an entirely different matter
but in terms of prior complaints some of
the earliest awareness that faith in
strangers had about the complaints that
were coming forward from ms wilson
powell and miss pritchard which to set
the record straight were aggressive in
nature were accompanied by
their attendance at the premises on the
outside through the car park with their
mobile phones against the wall of the
building
in order to be able to shazam the words
of the songs and they are on cctv
doing it and that cctv is available
so there are two sides to this story as
far as the occupation of flat three is
concerned it is a matter of fact
that the occupants moved in in 2019
the searches on their property would
have revealed the planning permission
and the license authorization it is a
second home
they do have a home in london and i will
be
making reference to the fact that this
is a classic agent of k of change case
which is a very important factor
they have chosen to go to the national
newspapers
this story appeared in the sun
yesterday or the day before faith in
strangers declined to comment because
they said it might prejudice these
proceedings clearly the residents did
not share
that compunction
the sound insulation let's look at that
as a technicality for a moment or two
um
to the extent that any of the residents
and i think it's mainly mrs walker in
flat nine purport to be able to make
a like for like comparison between the
sound attenuation that was in
frank's previously and what is in for
faith in strangers now
that is an inaccurate analysis
um
even to the point of trying to interpret
photographs as i say this is a highly uh
technical expertise the there were three
sets of acousticians involved
in the attenuation that was put in full
faith in strangers you will see at page
170 of the faith in strangers exhibits
kelvin joy
from techno timber construction who
gives a detailed blow by blow account of
the acoustic attenuation that was
installed for faith in strangers and the
acousticians actually reported in the
course of the licensing and the planning
proceedings the attenuation such as it
was that had been instituted what page
was that sorry 170 of the faith in
strangers exhibits
such attenuation that frank's had
had was degrading and crumbling and to a
certain extent collapsing to such an
extent that it was actually making the
situation worse this is a difficult
building to attenuate because it is
concrete and the residents many
apologies sorry once 170's michael kills
together we're stronger
didn't interrupt mr esca i wonder if i
might be allowed to continue renovated
i'm just trying to find out that's all i
i didn't interrupt you mr risky may i be
allowed to continue please
if you could show me if you could refer
me i'm looking then i've obviously taken
an incorrect note and no i'm not going
to be able to tell you write this very
minute without going through it myself
it's quite an unattractive tactic if i
may say so
um
the residents have mentioned the the
concrete uh
elements of the building and
particularly the pillars uh which
do conduct noise there's two elements of
noise uh
transfer as you may be aware airborne
and structure born
so far as the concrete pillars are
concerned one of the elements of the
attenuation put in by techno timber
construction
was to insulate and isolate the concrete
pillars and if you were to go into faith
in strangers you'd be able to see that
there is several feet of acoustic
material wrapped around the concrete
pillars in order to prevent the upward
transmission of sound through those
concrete pillars frank's did not have
that
it also did not have a number of the
elements that have currently been
installed
including the dropped sound ceiling
additional works have been done to faith
in strangers beyond that which was
required by the planning permission
licensing they have put in insulation
into a fire exit area
it is not correct to say that the only
way to attenuate a building like this is
to put a box within a box
a sound attenuation is a highly complex
matter
and this was very professionally done at
huge cost it's cost in excess of fifty
thousand pounds for faith in strangers
to put in that the noise uh insulation
that they they have done and they've
done more than they were required to do
and not less and environmental health
and licensing do not contend to the
contrary they obviously went out to
examine and assess the works that were
done they obviously had to sign off the
planning condition they did so they
signed themselves off as satisfied with
it so the council
has essentially approved the faith in
strangers sound attenuation twice
and were instrumental in saying what it
ought to be in the first place
i'm going to ask um the gentleman in due
course to comment on the speakers
themselves they're in a better position
than i am to do so
but the speakers are not
as the objectors are alleging either in
terms of capacity or description
may i ask you please to take a closer
look
at the withdrawal letter from
environmental health from miss amanda
berry that came out on the 2nd of
december of 2021. mr ranatunga has
referred to parts of it like to
emphasize the line that says sergeant
dropped again is that in the papers
apologies i i don't think i've seen that
letter could you just refer me i don't
know where it is mr escape i'm sorry it
will be in the papers yes it is
yes it will be just around
this is the noise abatement withdrawal
notice uh on the 2nd of december 2021.
mr aranatonga read it out earlier
as i was saying
the line reads although the council had
received several other complaints of
this nature from residents of
cliftonville court our investigations
had not proven a detriment to their
amenity
that was the reason given to faith in
strangers as to why the review was
withdrawn and the noise abatement notice
was withdrawn and that is the letter
that mr ranatunga
referred to now this is important
because that letter came in december
of last year
the representations
to which the residents speak to you
today came in in november of last year
and were based upon the complaints that
they had made to environmental health
prior to that you've seen
not that you should have done but you
have seen
the with the the review application and
the environmental health visits to
various flats and sites mr risque as
might be expected read out the ones
where the officers said they did
identify something that they would
describe as a nuisance there are more
again within that pack that i don't have
time to to take you to line for line but
i'd invite you to look at them if you're
going to look at it at all that say they
did not identify a nuisance so in other
words residents had called them out and
they assessed what it was that the
residents were listening to
and they did not assess it to be a
nuisance and wrote that down on their
visit form and in the same way
that was the decision that was taken and
was communicated to the club as to why
the review and the abatement notice were
withdrawn because despite
the complaints that the residents were
purporting to make and despite the
things that they were saying the
professional objective assessment of the
situation was that it was not a nuisance
and that is why this case uh is so uh
finally balanced in that description as
to what is a nuisance or not
the
officers
who attended um
gave their conclusions upon it and that
has been the uh the outcome of those
proceedings it would be incredibly
difficult if not impossible for
environmental health now to
go back on that position
and serve a further noise abatement
notice having so recently withdrawn one
or indeed to serve a further review so
shortly after these uh proceedings
furthermore you've heard from miss berry
through mr ranatunga today that although
certain people were complaining to the
environmental health department
when offered
intervention by environmental health for
some sort of investigation they declined
to do so
and i invite you to take that into
account as well
the further matters that the objectors
have raised in terms of people noise
outside whether
patrons or drunken persons or noisy
dispersal or bottles or fights or public
urination or anything of that sort
again was something that was discussed
and considered by mr brown um and
discounted as being something that could
be laid at the door of faith in
strangers the connection between them is
simply not there and for the reasons
that the gentleman that faith and
strangers
have put into their licensing statement
that this is a thoroughfare
and very many people walk up and down it
on their way to and from many different
places and although there are episodes
of antisocial behavior it's not accepted
that it emanates from these premises and
it's not accepted that they are
responsible for it and it is important
to note that that has never formed part
of environmental health's concerns they
did not put it into the noise abatement
notice
and it has not substantiated any of
their
uh
complaints against all their dealings
with the premises so that that's a very
difficult one uh to pin on these
premises and it's not accepted at all
at least one of the complaints from flat
3 that went to environmental health was
made on an occasion where faith in
strangers was closed the noise was
actually coming from a completely
different set of premises that were
conducting a wedding at the time
this is an unprecedented set of
proceedings in my experience it is
unheard of for an mp to appear before a
licensing committee of this sort in such
a partisan
position i i have some deep concerns
about the letters of support that the
council has rejected many of those
supporters have written to mr mckinley
asking for his support and input for
their
position in this case that the
response that they had back was that it
was not his responsibility to get
involved
and i have to draw that to attention
because he clearly has taken such a
strong line
in terms of being here and also in terms
of his comments in the press
which i
would invite the committee should they
have read them to completely disregard
when he talks about residential assets
in terms of their homes of course faith
in strangers is also
an asset
this i mentioned is a classic agent of
change case this is a situation where uh
in terms of the most recent comers to
the the block through the flats
this is akin to moving to the
countryside
next to the church and then complaining
about the church bells the freeholder
who has granted the lease has put
to the newer tenants who've been
incumbent since
uh since the freehold abort which i
gather was a bidding competition with
mrs walker at flat nine um which the the
current freeholder
prevailed in
um there are three clauses within the
leases that the most recent tenants have
taken
indicating
at clause 10 11 and 17
that they are not in a position to
complain about the
music and the entertainment use of the
premises underneath because it was
always envisaged that those uses would
have to coexist that those clauses in
the leases have been disregarded it is
also true to say that the freeholder has
offered to buy the leases of those who
regard themselves as the most affected
and as you've heard briefly touched upon
those offers have been
rejected
this is a lawful use of this site going
back for very many
years
in terms of
what the premises are entitled to do
even before faith in strangers
moved in
the there is no representation i've
indicated to you from the from planning
i've also uh
i should also mention there's been no
representation to you from the police
who would have something to say if they
regarded
there being any anti-social behavior
locally that was connected to the
premises
i'm going to
make a couple of
final comments in relation to
issues that i don't believe have been
taken into account in presenting this
case to the committee and this may be a
huge disservice to the committee you
have one paragraph
in your agenda pack alerting you to your
public sector equality duty as things
currently stand i have grave concerns
and i raise it as such with this
committee that that duty is not being
properly exercised
you may appreciate
what your duty involves
which has been set out very clearly uh
in the case law i need only read a line
or two about it in individual decisions
a decision maker must assess
the risk and extent of any adverse
impact of their decision
on any persons with protected
characteristics now one of the problems
of not receiving all of those letters of
support in good time
is that you i
hope this is not correct but i fear that
it is i've not had an adequate
opportunity to go through those letters
to consider what they are saying about
the impact of any
steps taken against faith in strangers
upon persons with protected
characteristics
the case law says that general regard to
issues of equality is not the same thing
as having specific regard to the
statutory criteria and public decision
makers must be properly informed before
taking a decision and if relevant
material is not available there's a duty
to acquire it which makes it all the
more concerning that all of those
letters of support
were not placed before you because many
of them talk about um the way in which
faith in strangers upholds their
interests as
persons of color or persons of minority
descent or persons of uh lgbtq plus
indication
or anything of that sort
any of the other protected
characteristics
it would be expected to be seen in a
decision of a committee of this sort as
to how they've taken those
representations into account when
deciding if anything uh what steps they
are prepared to take
i'm also going to refer you and your
legal advisor will be aware of it of
paragraph 42
of the hope and glory case in the court
of appeal in which lord justice tolson
gave a 360 degree overview of the
considerations that were relevant
to a licensing committee such as
yourselves
and one of the key considerations that
he set out was the importance to the
local economy
the importance to the visiting public
people who actually use the premises and
the importance to the licensee
themselves sometimes it's presented as
if running a business were a dirty and
underhand thing to be doing it's quite
the reverse as i hope the letters of
support make abundantly clear and the
contribution that faith in strangers
makes overall
to margate
the support from the music venue trust
and the night time industries
association i generally highlight
and can i conclude my remarks by saying
this faith in strangers mr duffy mr
randall
have always
and will continue to work as closely as
possible with environmental health with
licensing and with any other authority
with whom their
cooperation is is required
in the course of these proceedings it
has been my advice
for them to conclude these proceedings
and conclude the court proceedings
because they're in a litigation
situation
and that is not a good time
to be engaging in open discussions and
negotiations with particular outcomes
that does not mean that they are
refusing to cooperate or to
to discuss what it is that environmental
health would wish to discuss they
maintain a best practicable means
position they have done everything that
they can do going above and beyond what
the authorities to date have required of
them they have
put rubber stoppers on the bottoms of
chairs the photographs are there for you
to see they have sought to address
hand dryers and any noise that might
arise from them they have
acoustically attenuated a fire exit area
that they were concerned might possibly
be a route of transmission they've done
a number of different things they will
continue their cooperative discussions
once these proceedings are
concluded um those things were not part
of the noise abatement notice i have to
highlight hand dryers and chairs were
not in the noise abatement notice it was
purely uh music from machinery which is
a slightly unusual way of putting it but
that is what the noise abatement notice
said so clearly so far as environmental
health were concerned that was what they
were focusing upon um but faith and
strangers completely understand their
responsibilities
to try and ameliorate any reasonable
complaints that are being made against
them unfortunately and this is an
unfortunate case not everything that has
been leveled at them has been by any
standards reasonable and on certain
occasions quite the contrary um and this
this
is
going to be a very difficult case to
bring to a final conclusion by the
sounds of things can i
ask um mr randall and or mr duffy to
give you a little bit more information
on the speakers specifically
that's great and so yeah mr um randall
mr duffy and mr ford
would like to
add to that
um thank you madam speaker i'm going to
talk briefly about the um speaker system
just to clarify because we feel there's
been some um mistruths or
misunderstandings around
what exactly we have installed in the in
the building
and there are two
essentially two distinct systems
and the first is the
function one sound system which
comprises of um several small speakers
and that around about this size i think
we've got the size here there
35 by 25 centimeters
and they're all on acoustic um rubber
isolators that mean that their vibration
into the structure um is negated by that
um and they're spread throughout the
building rather than what a
nightclub or a solely music venue would
do which would be to have one source of
sound we've spread it throughout at a
smaller at a lower level
so that um
wherever you are in the building
and the music can be played at a lower
level rather than loud from one source
if that makes sense
then
on top of that and the the additional
system is the klipsch um which is a
domestic hi-fi
system with a valve amp
um i noticed that clips have been picked
up on their tagline and we don't choose
sound systems based on their advertising
um
the the system is typically used for
more of a listening experience with
um earlier on in the evening with jazz
and sol and so forth it's not used later
on in the evening in any case
um i think that's is there anything to
add to that jerry
um
can you hear me yeah um
now the only thing is um about the
frank's soundproofing i wanted to bring
up is
is that that structure made things
infinitely worse it wasn't decoupled at
all so it was a wooden structure drilled
straight into the concrete it had no
rubber isolation had nothing it was it
made things worse our acoustician
said that and obviously donna picked up
on the on the water damage as well so
um
i think actually the freehold freeholder
actually took that structure
it was um derelict at that point
um
but yeah i mean we were told um by
professionals that that would have made
the scenario worse hence why i guess
frank thorley had to buy
five or so of the flats above
madam chair i think mr ford wanted to
speak but we do have um the counsellor
here who is one of our witnesses and
down on the regulation ain't noticed
um
did you say the council got your
counselors talking for mr ford
no no this is mr ford here but we
submitted a regulation eight notice with
four names on it um
counselor rob yates was one of those
names okay that's great thank you
um thank you very much uh chair and good
afternoon everyone um my name's rob
yates i'm a local resident in thailand
since
margate since 2017
and the councillor for margate central
uh margaret central doesn't specifically
cover this area um just for that
information and i've been that counselor
since 2019 so
during the pandemic um
just to put all my cards on the table i
want to be as transparent and open as
possible as possible i worked as shadow
cabinet for finance um within the
council and within that role
supporting businesses
ensuring they were connected with
the right business grants throughout the
pandemic and finding a way to keep than
its economy alive
um unfortunately it was not around when
this venue is uh frank's nightclub so i
cannot easily speak to that
um so over the pandemic i found faith in
strangers um to be an invaluable
invaluable workspace to myself uh
because we were being told
to work from home
and i found the opportunity were there i
have attended many of their evening
events
as a customer
and have been have become to know the
hard-working uh business owners uh
richard and jeremy
just say firstly that has been portrayed
throughout this evening as a nightclub
um so apart from one live music event
where there were where there was
predominantly people standing
um every other night i've been to and
probably been to about
10 to 15.
um
we you do see people sat down they sat
down at the workspace of
like seating areas and the music is such
that you are able to easily talk to each
other through the music um i just want
to say that the vive is not so much a
nightclub but more of a fancy bar
um and quite enough quite often on
events i've been to specifically over
the last few months
there haven't been enough customers to
keep the venue open until two in the
morning so they have been closing early
so today i'll be briefly explaining the
licensing objectives that i put forward
in my submission
i briefly then want to make some wider
points highlighting my support for faith
and strangers
and that and the benefit to the
community of thana and the wider economy
that they do make
um
so firstly just going on to prevention
of crime and disorder so as i've
highlighted they've got a doorbell um
checking people in and out they've got
security on friday and saturday evenings
making sure the people are behaving
themselves as they come in and out and
they will check on people as you're
outside because i do go outside when i'm
smoking at the venue
because i'm not allowed to use the
balcony based on the noise specific
issues that they want to avoid
according to faith and strangers the
only time the police have come inside is
after a woman is found to be hiding from
domestic abuse so i've come into the
night to
avoid that
um as highlighted um a few times during
the fit out of the space the tdc
environment health officer witnessed the
insulation measures
christopher brown sadly he seems to no
longer work at tdc as if they feel like
his involvement would be um
beneficial to the parties
so
i do completely understand noise issues
and
like i've lived in arlington house with
single glazing outside the front
i see it by the roundabout working up
all times at night so i do understand it
and especially with the scaffolding
outside the building during the day time
which you do hear within faith and
strangers
the works going on there
i can only imagine the frustration there
must be to have noise in the evening as
well
going on to the kind of the concrete
pillars
i actually measured up these the pillars
the size of them because i wanted that
because that is a key thing that they
have done with noise insulation um and
the pillars
according to the records
um according what richard told me they
were 30 centimeters and you can see that
in the picture they are very narrow
pillars and now they are 85 centimeters
and i witnessed
that being measured um with rockwool
insulation inside
so
so that's on the pillars the floor the
new material metal floor has isolation
in it to dump in the noise from what i'm
hearing um
i believe there was no dampening of that
noise um at frank's
time
um the ceiling of faith in strangers so
again already mentioned
f1 sound were involved and the council
involved in the
the creation of that kind of noise
dampening system
and i have seen with my own eyes the
double glazing that they have put into
small windows that are in the top
and that was done
after the in
so initially they just had double
glazing but then they had secondary
glazing put in
once
some noise issues occurred
for my understanding but i've seen the
secondary glazing so it definitely
exists and that secondary glazing exists
for from uh throughout
that structure so i think that's
important to notice
balcony usage so i love standing outside
uh looking at the sunset having a drink
but they'll only allow drinking in the
balcony until 10 o'clock
due to noise
nine o'clock sorry i put 10 o'clock in
my con in my submission though
um and again they won't let allow that
for smoking even though i'm a smoker um
i can convince them of that um speakers
so i think we've gone through speakers
um
i have had i've highlighted
the the noise little dyson hand dryers
i'm not a fan of dyson hand dryers
and they are installing some additional
insulation i believe
around that that sounds like it's been
completed
um i just like highlight that compared
with other night clubs i don't use that
term loosely i think it's more of a bar
um compared with kabuki margate all the
nightclubs in canterbury i find it much
too quiet in there
um
and obviously like i've been to a few
night clubs in my time but
i'm surprised that they don't increase
the noise to have more dancing because
most of the time people are sat down um
so that's that's my personal view going
on to protection of children from harm
they've got an age verification policy
they keep a log book when they reject
people at the door public safety first
aid kit is under the bar
they follow strict measures uh strict
measures for alcohol to ensure they
don't pour over five-star food and
hygiene ring kent fire and rescue
have praised them according to uh um the
owners
and they've successfully held events for
that incident including pride events um
but i'll go on to that uh briefly so
that's just
my overview of what i've submitted um
however i think we're allowed to just
discuss wider issues briefly um
so
firstly the
hello yates um you've um exceeded the
five minutes now okay
so did mp mckinley
so it would be
okay thank you very much i'm wrapping up
um
so
yeah we are seeing businesses struggling
in summit and i do have serious concern
that if one resident can start a review
of licensing planning
opening up licensing planning conditions
then other businesses across the
across the area will feel nervous and
will feel scared by that
as already mentioned i think um
it's important to know the environment
health
have formally kind of withdrawn um
from today and it's
and that's i think a key point but um
just just that
go on some what mr mckinley said finally
about what faith and strangers have done
for the community um so they've hosted a
power of women livestream event during
the pandemic they've fundraised for our
kitchen food club they've hosted a
family-friendly technology meetup
hosted an evening skatepark launch as
part of the margate town deal
they've had queer djs perform and they
continue to work with the community of
thanet so for all those reasons i hope
the committee do not open up the full
licensing review as to do so go against
the environmental health recommendations
in front of you
um it could be seen as a threat to other
late-night businesses across planet um
who have really struggled during the
pandemic
and could result in further legal action
thank you
thank you
mr ford was going to
it was only a very brief procedural
point is that um
we're mainly here to observe and advise
but we were one of the organizations
that submitted
a representation within within the time
we put quite a detailed submission in
which our letter has been included as
part of their evidence but we've never
received any acknowledgement or any
explanation from the local authority of
why it wasn't included or even
acknowledging its existence so i think
that that is quite a significant
procedural concern because there's an
another 135 i think
organizations that didn't get any
response and my understanding is that
anyone making representations behalf of
the local authority got sent a pro forma
but we didn't even get that opportunity
to actually to look at our
representation if they felt that it
didn't fit some of the criteria but we
did do quite a detailed submission
and
the the main purpose of the music
ventures is to work with venues and
local authorities and residents to try
to come to kind of resolution so we are
we are trying to work with the venue and
we will continue to advise the venue but
we are quite disappointed that such a
simple procedural procedure wasn't
followed
as noted
does the licensing team have any
questions for those representing faith
and strangers
no
does environmental health have any
questions
cerise gay do you have any questions
thank you yes um sorry ms clover you
stated
um and could you please explain why a
noise abatement or a view couldn't be
served so soon just because they've been
withdrawn if
the operator changes his modus operandi
fires a salvo and keeps operating it
loud
loud music why why would it not be
appropriate for a noise abatement or a
view not to be served i don't understand
the logic i wasn't talking about a
hypothetical or a speculative situation
where changing tack or changing uh
operation i was talking about the
reality on the ground
so disputing the evidence that's been
put before you today
i'm sorry so you're disputing what's
been said by the residents today
i had hoped that i had made that
abundantly clear thank you um sorry for
mr randall mr duffy in terms of the
speakers
obviously i don't know speakers but
obviously you've heard uh and it's been
witnessed within the the reports that
lyrics can be heard from songs in the
residence do you think no speaker that
speaker system works
does it what do you mean work well i
mean
i
mean
does it stop attenuation does it stop it
traveling is it a system that works and
means that you can function as a night
club i think i'm not i think
it could be a hell of a lot worse and
we've
designed that system with that in mind
to try and stop the transmission
thank you
i mean they're 35 by 25 centimeters so
it's not a normal
i think we got referred to as a festival
sound system i think a festival sound
system would usually be a few meters
high and it would have 20 speakers or so
that's lovely thank you
no that's all i've got thank you
do um yes craig pinnock's residents um
um who submitted representations like
yours yourself included thank you just
really to miss clover as she sort of
mentioned be mine by name it's clover
clover i'm so sorry
it's clover uh as she mentioned me um
you mentioned church bells which is an
interesting point uh we had a noise
abatement order in sandwich recently so
is this a question
it is you said it people would move into
an area complain and have to put up with
it well exactly the same happened in
sandwich and the church bells were
closed down uh or stopped now you say
i've acted in a partisan way can i just
i didn't understand the question about
the church bells could you put it again
please yep
you said that people what was the
question the question was you said it
doesn't happen well i'm afraid it does
because it happened locally no i didn't
say it didn't happen i said it does
happen and it's right okay well we've
clarified the point between us that's
great uh you you accused me of acting in
a partisan way
now it is unusual and i'm sure it
happens with other people so is this a
question
i
want to clarify the point that you put
to me you put to me you put to me that
i've acted in a partisan way
i will put a question then
um you rather ingenious and with great
ingenuity i must admit and i and i
really do uh commend you for it you you
you will the question be coming soon it
is you you woven your arguments equality
act 2010 on the public sector equality
duty can you just answer to me
do your clients have a disabled access
allowing um wheelchair access to their
premises that's not relevant to a
licensing hearing
it's not a relevant point for a
licensing hearing it's not well then
objectives don't answer them that's
absolutely fine uh as part of your
submissions you said officers did these
officers did that things didn't raise to
the threshold that was required
are you actually saying that the
officer's word is
the highest standard that people should
go along with and are you calling all of
these residents in making their
complaints therefore liars
i think my submissions have been
abundantly clear and i don't have
anything else to say about it no that's
fine thank you
to any of the other um residents um who
submitted representations have any
questions um for those representing
faith and strangers may i ask a question
um
do you believe that it is reasonable
for the residents of cliftonville court
including the children and toddlers to
be subjected to the noise nuisance that
you create
i'm sorry that's not that's not a
question for me that is a question for
the committee that that's not an
empirical question that that's a
judgmental question and it's for the
matter for the committee it doesn't
matter what i think
could you repeat that question i didn't
catch that sorry i i was i was asking
whether or not um miss clover felt that
it was reasonable which i appreciate i
haven't phrased particularly well um
that residents would be subjected to the
noise nuisance that we are being
subjected to i i really does beg a
belief to me i i don't quite understand
where the walls of common decency have
gone why would you set up a business
that puts us all through this and sit
there and defend it i just
i'm just curious sorry right
i'm not able to ask questions
okay
i'm sorry do members of the um
committee have any questions um to ask
thank you chair um i've got one question
to ask mr reynolds and mr duffy
i've heard you talk about all the
singing and dancing insulation and
advice that you put in and ask for have
you actually ever asked the residents if
you could come up to their flat when the
noise is being made so you can hear it
yes we have
council rogers
to hear the noise when it's happening to
which he said yes
okay yeah we just to clarify we've been
in how about he thought he was so we've
been to um flat three um with miss
pritchard and
um
flat two with mary strachan who's sadly
no longer with us
can i just say you didn't you weren't
you didn't come into our flat when
you're having a night you've never been
up to one of our flats when you're
having a night on and mary died last
april before you opened or reopened
um
we had open by the time we went to visit
mary
also we we
played the sound as loud as we thought
we would ever go probably louder so it's
kind of
that doesn't really make sense
but you haven't
i mean we've been up numerous times
and the last time we came up we got
accused of
you know we're not
i think the relationship broke quite
early on didn't it
unfortunately so it appears even before
we moved in sorry please may i ask one
question to miss clover um you suggest
that i was shazaming a track on the ramp
could i ask how you know or why you
think i was just having a track uh it's
on cctv
may i make a point of clarity
clarification on that
uh i had a complaint from resident here
uh jackie that from top floor she could
see strobe lighting i was filming that i
did at the same time make a recording on
the noise app
the environmental health team will be
able to confirm they've had one
recording from outside the premises
which i marked very clearly as being
outside the premises i only took that
because i was recalling the strobe
lighting at the same time
one occasion
um
members of the committee you've got any
more questions i'm councillor rogers
thank you
um
if this isn't a nightclub can you tell
me why the dj that's that's coming
obviously on saturday um says he's going
to rip the roof off that sounds pretty
heavy to me
um
it's a it's just an expression it's a
way to generate excitement around
someone who's coming to play records
it's obviously not there's no
tearing the roof off
i've got a question
um when you initially um put in your
application to um planning and licensing
was your intention at that point to have
like an arts an arts venue which was
basically to have academic speakers
poetry i mean i understand like the
working the workspace as well because
all of that is like amazing only because
today when i look on your facebook page
there's lots of djs listed that are
playing techno jungle i mean these are
the kinds kind of like nightclubby type
of djs
so it's like it's like a hybrid you know
like a nightclub you know one minute
then sort of arts um work space the next
so so i was just thinking you know like
it was a bit confusing the original
licensing and planning application
and
i was just wondering if the intention
was always to have these sort of like
heavy techno electronic djs right from
the beginning
and we typically we don't really have
techno and we've never had jungle but um
we do have djs on fridays and saturday
nights and we consider the musical
aspect and aspects of art and culture
um and we see music as the foremost art
of the time so we refute the idea that
it couldn't be included in that
and
we do have we've held margaret science
festival as rob mentioned um we we did a
whole festival
um around the margaret power of women
um
brand um we we've done spoken word
poetry we've done talks and we'll
continue to do that
um it's it's part of a
holistic cultural program but as is
mentioned in our statement of truth
um
the all of those aspects um don't
generate the funds to cover the costs of
running a building like that which is
why frank's nightclub and starlight
before
just relied solely on the djs
much more frequently than we did
we
really it's
mostly a friday and saturday night thing
with the occasional i think the the
wednesday night event there referring to
i think was a
office christmas party
so
yeah if you want to add so
um
i guess the other thing to bear in mind
is that
this has taken up all of our time
and djs are very easy they're very easy
to put on they don't take too much
production and all the rest of it
so
we need to we've got debt i mean we've
got an innovation loan from kent county
council we we have lots of debts that we
need to cover
djs are very simple it's one person
uh they're mainly locals so we don't
even have to put them up or anything we
don't have to pay for travel
bans and all the other arts and culture
take a lot more programming and a lot
more detailing so if we got ironically
if we had our energy
and time to do that we would have put on
a lot more
of the you know
spoken word or whatever but um
that that's
another reason why why that's happening
and we've programmed that
madam chairman i'll just clarify a
couple of things that you have said uh
i'm not sure where the techno and jungle
djs um sorry
um yes i was actually going to clarify
that um that the techno and the jungle
djs are actually is actually how they're
described on the facebook website for
the venue
that doesn't necessarily indicate what
they're playing on on the night um my
instructions are
if everybody's quite finished um sorry
so so they're separate djs for like
different nights and those djs
underneath it it states what genre of
music they play
we haven't done a single techno night
there might be a night where a techno
record gets played but it's not the
whole little bit holding
you wouldn't have to look back very far
i mean i'm talking i'm talking about if
you went onto the facebook page now you
could find that very easily
yeah i'd say predominantly our and the
music we play would would be in um disco
and soul and house jazz we don't i don't
think there's i mean i've never had a
jungle record played in there maybe the
occasional techno but it's probably more
like to be ambient techno or called
drone techno which is a much more
uh slower paced affair
manchester united can i also raise this
point in terms of the cultural offering
you've got a number of letters of
support in the one three five one three
seven letters of support that came in
that described
the cultural
events that people have been involved in
can i just clarify
at this point in time whether the
committee has read
those letters of support yeah i did hear
you referring to that earlier one we we
were sent all of the letters um so so
yes we have had the opportunity and i
have read through the letters of support
um you know and also i can you know like
clarify that most of those letters were
about you know how how good it you know
the the overall is for the community and
you know what a good establishment is
etc and how it's well run um obviously
what we were looking for was like um
noise nuisance
there are numerous references within
those letters and i'd be happy to give
you the page references if need be that
talk directly to the licensing
objectives and those letters as mr ford
has indicated should have been before
you as relevant representations
but in terms of the specifics of what
people are saying
as i've said it's it's not to be
disregarded because they are go to your
pscd
to um the committee have any other
questions um
for the representative faith and
strangers know okay
all right
so summing up
i would now like to ask each party to
sum up and make final representations um
mr anatunga and the environmental health
team do you wish to make any final
comments
no madam i've set out our position
earlier okay
thank you
um mr esque please can you make your
final comments um
up to 15 minutes oh thank you no i won't
need that long um just so that you're
wearing the committee's aware i hadn't
been putting put on notice of the
protective characteristics argument that
miss clover has raised today uh and
therefore can't respond to that
um in terms of um miss clover uh read
out the hope and glory case i actually
happen to have it and i can hand up
cases but just so it's not disingenuous
i'll just read uh the full transcripts
of 41 as mr matthias rightly submitted
the licensing function of a licensing
authority is an administrative function
by contrast the function of a district
judge is a judicial function the
licensing authority has a duty in
accordance with the rule of law to
behave fairly in the decision-making
procedure but the decision itself is not
a judicial or quasar judicial act it is
an exercise of power delegated by the
people as a whole to decide what the
public interest requires that was 41 and
then 42
licensing decisions often involve
weighing a variety of competing
considerations the demand for licensed
establishments the economic benefits to
the proprietor and to the locality by
drawing in visitors and stimulating the
demand and the effect of law and order i
think that's what miss
clover said however she missed out the
impact of the lives of those who live
and work in the vicinity and so on
sometimes a licensing decision may
involve narrow questions such as whether
noise noxious smells or litter coming
from the premises amount to the public
nuisance although such questions are
incensed questions of fact they're not
questions of the heads or tails variety
they involve an evaluation of what is to
be regarded as reasonably acceptable in
the particular location in any case
deciding what if any conditions should
be attached to a licence as necessary
and proportionate to the promotion the
statutory licensing objectives is
essentially a matter of judgment rather
than a matter of pure fact
moving on then chair please
as per section 1119 of the section 182
guidance all options are open uh to the
committee today uh including uh we would
say revocation due to the behavior of
the operator and their unwillingness to
engage um when clearly there are noise
issues
um for clarity again uh just to confirm
my clients have been uh obviously the
agent of change principles been arranged
my clients have been in their flat for
two and a half years
there were no issues until it was a
transfer to a nightclub and therefore
that's when the complaint started so my
clients were resident in the premises
prior to it becoming a nightclub not two
and a half years prior to becoming a
nightclub but were in place
uh at no stage are they trying to to
stop any of the co-working space uh if
it was as per
um the planning application and the
licensing application there'd be no
issues
we stand by the fact that the operating
style has clearly changed and obviously
you've heard much discussion uh council
yates even referred to it as a nightclub
himself
objection i said the vibe
you said the vibe wasn't nighttime but
you i said more like a bar and you've
just misrepresented my words sorry has
made that correction i'll take that back
um
there were no complaints um prior to
this transition
we say that there clearly is a public
nuisance the residents as you've heard
and as in the written correspondence um
directly affected by faith in strangers
nightclub operation
shielding behind
franks
and planning simply doesn't wash as it
doesn't address the issues
rather than attempt to mitigate the
problems they've fought at this hearing
and every opportunity to work against
the residents rather than working with
the residents
which we say is against
the promotion of the licensing
objectives
it's not just the loud noise
but also the reveller noise
in terms of we did try and report it to
the police but they said it was an eh
issue so that was mentioned as to why we
hadn't been to the police we had been
and they said it was an eh issue with
the revelers outside
uh but it's also the furniture and the
hand dryers
as you've heard uh
since
december and january when ehr have
become re-engaged they've indicated that
there are high levels
from recent test results
and that they have concerns there is an
issue you've heard from the residents
has the premises done everything it
could reasonably expected to do
and we would clearly say no for in our
eyes they've chosen a business plan uh
over the residence
and for that reason
we would request
that
all licenseable activities be reduced to
2300 daily
this will eliminate the the noise
transmission and indeed the noise from
the revelers
the electric hand drives be replaced
with a system that doesn't create noise
that all furniture have uh rubber socks
uh and that importantly that you remove
the live music act exemption uh with the
deregulation of life and recorded music
from before 2300
and that a noise limiter condition is
added
um to the levels to be set and agreed
with environmental health doesn't cause
a nuisance to my clients
so those are my submissions thank you
do any of the residents wish to make any
final comments
i've been said but
oh sorry tribute
i just wonder
i hope i'm not out of order saying this
but i just wondered um
um the thing about a business um these
gentlemen then losing their business um
i may be wrong but i understand that
they receive grants from the local
authority because they're a community
center like it's a community space so if
that's true then i'll say that losing a
music license would not be that much
they've got like another business to
fall back on
that's all i wanted to say
miss clover um can you make your final
comments please
yes thank you the point about grants you
can't live off grants
particularly throughout the coronavirus
crisis they have been life-saving not
business sustaining
uh we're talking about business
viability and this is nothing new
uh unfortunately would it were different
um spoken word and poetry
and arts presentations of different
types
are not sufficient to sustain a business
if we want them at all
we have to supplement them
with
enterprises that make money and that is
exactly what lord justice tolson was
talking about in hope and glory i'm
grateful to mr risque for reading out
the paragraph it is the one i referred
to
i know it very well i could probably
recite it in my sleep and the justice as
i said was giving a
360 degree view of licensing because
that is what it is it is not the
exclusive purview
of one contingency or another
it is a a fully rounded view
of what is reasonable and appropriate
in accordance with the views of many
people and faith in strangers
uh
is not as it is being characterized here
it is absolutely
fundamentally rejected
that the business model has changed in
any way or shape and i don't hear the
authorities claiming that to you you
have not had a representation from the
licensing authority saying all bets are
off everything's changed nor does
environmental health say that to you nor
does planning the police have not said
anything that is the position of your
responsible authorities and the section
182 guidance makes it very plain that
you take your expert
advice your expert input from your
experts
and should be primarily and
fundamentally guided by what the
professional witnesses and responsible
authorities say to you on those specific
points
there have been coveted lockdowns which
might have had an impact on the output
from the business other than that it has
been absolutely continuous including djs
including music including everything
that it was always designed to achieve
because it was never going to be viable
without it and as you can imagine
competent business people do their
business models before they open they
don't change tack
part way in and certainly not in such a
short period as two years
to realize they've made a terrible
terrible mistake and they're not going
to be able to make a profit out of
poetry
that is not what has happened here by a
long shot that the residents and mr
reese gay on their behalf tell you that
this is a public nuisance environmental
health have put it in writing that it is
not
and for that reason they have withdrawn
the noise abatement notice and the
review because
it is not
after their
independent investigations
a noise nuisance for you to find
otherwise
based on what residents are telling you
it would be a very big and may i say
dangerous step indeed i have objected to
mr ranatunga presenting the review
application to you which i maintain he
has in fact done that's a legal error
and shouldn't have happened but in any
event that is what you have in front of
you and that investigation that review
application terminated with a withdrawal
and a letter expressing the uh
absolutely outright conclusion that
there was not a public nuisance and what
you cannot do
is now make a decision based on
speculative future
concerns that environmental health might
have
upon which there is not a shred of
evidence before you
mr ranatunga updated you again entirely
wrongly
and outside the purview of any uh
application that had been put before you
or any representation i maintain
environmental health and not actually
technically here
but it was quite quite wrong for him to
indicate to you in generalized
vague terms what might be happening with
environmental health now and without
readings without
site visits without officer notes you
have no clue
as to what that situation is and to base
a decision upon it
at this stage would be entirely wrong
i'm not clear in my final point i'm not
clear what it is you are being asked
to do i don't know what the relevance of
11 o'clock is said to be
why that hour as opposed to any other
curtailing the hours for these premises
as they've made very very plain these
time to mount to a revocation
and there mustn't be any doubt about
that cutting the hours back is the same
thing
as terminating the business they cannot
and will not survive on hours other than
those that they put in for and were
granted
in terms of putting in a noise limiter
the environmental health department
don't ask for it you would be imposing
something that environmental health do
not ask for themselves and on the basis
that they would be the ones expected to
marshall and administer it that creates
a complication in and of itself
and then finally
conditions as to the spec specifics of
hand dryers and rubber feet on chairs
firstly it's been done already and
secondly i don't know how you would word
a condition like that i've never seen it
never seen it done
and if the residents saw fit to invite
you to do so one might have thought that
they would draft a condition for you to
consider in advance and for us all to
comment upon but my strong contention to
you is that it simply isn't possible
unless i can help you that's what i'd
wish to say
thank you miss clover um mr randall mr
duffy mr ford um are there any final
comments you'd like to make
yeah i'd just like to reiterate that um
the last comments or towards the end of
what sarah said it will it will
essentially close us down if that
happens we've invested nearly half a
million pounds into that property it was
a derelict site
um
it's one of the most prominent buildings
in cliftonville and i i firmly believe
that we're a positive part of the
regeneration for a wider community and
we employ mainly local people who grew
up in tennent we're training them to
open their own businesses
we've got numerous workspace
people that rely on us for their mental
health as well as particularly during
covid a lot of them have moved down here
by themselves
loads of them have said they would move
they would move out back up margot if if
we close down and that's in our letters
and um
yeah i mean i just hope i hope that
those restrictions aren't put upon us
because
that would be the end of us basically
let's see
sorry can i just clarify it did eho did
say a noise limiting device and that was
on page 14. miss clover said it wasn't
no i didn't if mr risco would listen so
very carefully to my submissions i said
that they have withdrawn
their application they are no longer
asking for it
apologies
is that all clear now
okay good thank you okay so thanks very
much um the committee members um
democratic service officer and the legal
officer will now leave the room to make
their deliberations and we will return
back to the council chamber for the
decision to be announced
so back in about half an hour
hello again um
i'd now like to um invite miss phillips
and the principal litigation sister to
read a summary of um the subcommittee's
determination
thank you
in the application for a full review of
the license for faith in strangers 17
athelbert crescent margate having
considered documentation and
representations
made to the board on the 17th of
february
and considered representations from the
license and technical support manager
the report she gave
the licensing department
from mr ranatunga for the
environmental health department
representations from the interested
parties who are represented by mr risque
and from miss clover
for faith in strangers
i would say also that um it wasn't just
an easy decision that was reached by the
committee
the committee considered the steps that
may be taken further to section 52 4
of the licensing act which includes
steps such as modifying the conditions
of the license
excluding a license support activity
or removing the designated premises of a
supervisor or suspend the license for a
particular period of time or to revoke
the license now these are the steps to
that may be taken further to an
application which has been made by a
responsible authority or any other
person
on this occasion the application to
review the license
has been withdrawn and the subcommittee
accepts that withdrawal haven't been
assisted by the representations that
were made by mr ranatunga for the
environmental health department
the subcommittee have been greatly
assisted by the representations made by
the residents and their representative
however in the absence of an application
by another person in accordance with
section 51 the subs committee are unable
to take the steps provided
by section 52.
those representations have enabled the
subcommittee to give proper
consideration to the reasons given for
the withdrawal of the application to
review
the application to review is withdrawn
and there can be no review of the
application further to this hearing
today
the subcommittee do make various
recommendations
which
expresses that they recognize the
competing interests of both parties
which include to add to the local
economy and the well-being of the
residents
and
recommend steps to be taken for all the
parties to collaborate in achieving a
resolution to the sound proven issues
that emanate from the
premises
and secondly if this is not achieved the
relevant authority
or the other party
should make an application for a review
if it's deemed appropriate based on the
evidence
and that's the decision of the
subcommittee today
thank you
and that's the end of the meeting